this is Jocko podcast number 87 with
echo Charles and me Jocko willing
good evening echo good evening I'd been
away from infantry and from the army I'd
grown up in for far too long walking
through the gates of Colman barracks was
stepping into the welcome past the old
army had not died after all the 18th was
military perfection men stepped smartly
across meticulously kept grounds
starched uniforms blue infantry scarves
dazzling shined brass and boots snappy
salutes and cheerful good afternoon sirs
marked my journey to the HQ where I
design in the spirit of this fine unit
was already infecting me the hot
stifling windless day the ragweed pollen
that blew in from adjacent fields
covering the camp and immediately
activating my hay fever the rundown
boring camp itself none of it mattered
as inwardly I was transported to an
island Oasis untouched by turbulent seas
and it was all thanks to one man the
Battle Group commanding officer who
would forever be my model mentor and
friend Colonel Glover s John's was the
finest senior infantry commander I'd
ever seen or ever would see again we
shared a mutual abiding respect almost
from the moment we met
he was my kind of soldier and I was his
he was a warrior Patton's aid before
World War two then during the war he'd
hit the beaches of Normandy as part of
the 29th division and fought from those
bloody shores all the way across Europe
until victory was achieved as a
battalion commanding officer he'd headed
the task force to capture the critical
French town of saint-lo
in Korea he'd served as executive
officer than regimental commander in my
own 40th division his reputation there
was awesome one story that made its way
through the division was that a wild new
excel had come into the to to forth
gotten down on his belly in the mud to
check the unit's machine guns field of
fire and promptly moved two thirds of
the machine-gun bunkers that had sat
there for two years later when he took
over his commanding officer the 224th
and the unit moved to a new sector he'd
out posted a spur about 200 yards in
front of one of his companies so the
North Koreans couldn't do it first but
this move was considered seizing ground
and against the no-win rules of the war
and soon the XCore commanding general
flew down the John's position to discuss
the matter with him after exam examining
the situation general white told him he
could keep the spur but was never to
advanced again even his outpost line
without express permission from Corps
because blue eyes sparkled like those of
a wise and truly tested man who long
since realized that humor could be found
in just about anything he had seen his
share of horror his cheeks were rosy and
the dueling scar that crossed one of
them in no way detracted from his Ghent
rugged yet gentle old soldier face maybe
the scar even enhanced it I don't know
but it sure gave him more character then
provided a good yarn to boot in any
event
Colonel Glover s John's was a 49 year
old stud
Colonel John's was a basics man and a
total soldier he taught and insisted
that his company commanders teach things
like terrain appreciation the knowledge
of which was a basic tool of a soldiers
trade to be able to look at a piece of
ground and appreciate
the slightest differences in the contour
to notice how the ground unfolds and be
able to think there's cover over there
cover the one essential providing
protection from direct enemy fire to
recognize a streamline a gully or a
treat area as an avenue of approach
through which a unit could move unseen
to understand and identify the best
ground from which to launch or repel an
attack shoot scoot and communicate the
morning battle drill began with fire and
maneuver one-man firing while his buddy
moved a fireteam moving while its
counterpart fired Colonel John's likened
it to a fighter's bobbing weaving and
jabbing we kept the mythical enemy
pinned down while we jabbed our way to
close on his position
that's cover and moved by the way the
colonel was right there with us to set
the example and we did it until we got
it right we'd end up black and blue
running hitting the ground and rolling
into firing position with full field
equipment on is not without pain but no
one bitched because John's again and
again reinforced a simple equation the
quicker you get to the ground and you
get your weapon into position the sooner
you'll be delivering effective fire on
the enemy and the longer you'll stay
alive still this truism was just one
part of the overall strive to better
your best philosophy that characterized
the first year of the 18th under Colonel
John's and deputy commanding officer
couch in couches words it was our policy
to encourage excellence among the
soldiers particularly in bayonet
training unarmed combat shooting and
total physical fitness this is what
really makes a soldier if he mashed
masters these subjects he'll fight for
my experience in Korea I could not have
agreed more
so that's a little opener from a book
called about-face my favorite book by
it's written by colonel david hackworth
and he's talking about a guy that was
his commander in the early 1960s hackers
had gotten out of the army and then came
back in after a couple years because he
realized civilian life was not fun and
so he came back in and he got stationed
in Germany and this guy by the name of
Colonel Glover s John's who by the way
he did a course which dedicates he
dedicates the book to infantrymen into
some other soldiers that he worked with
long away but to Glover Jones he says
dedicates his book to Glover Jones who
showed us how to lead
so Glover Jones outstanding combat
leader and luckily we can all learn from
Glover Jones not only from what he
passes through hackworth in hack words
book but also from his own book club
arrest challenge wrote his own book
called the clay pigeons of saint-lo
about his push from Normandy and across
France that Hackworth just referenced
now it's interesting when we go into
this book the clay pigeons is Salo he
writes the book in the third person and
he says that it was just easier for him
to write it that way so in other words
he doesn't say I did this and I did that
he says major Jones did this and major
dodge John said something else but
what's interesting is he said that one
of the reasons he was able to do one of
the reasons that he did that was because
the guy that was commanding in combat
was a battalion commander and comment
was different from his normal self
hmm as we had this combat John's combat
Glover Jones I was out there leading
things and he had normal John's that was
the way he lived his normal life but it
was easier for him to write and more
natural for him to write about this
major John's guy in the third person he
also lexically can give him it gives me
the ability to kind of detach from it
and explain what was going on so when
you hear it it's all about major John's
instead of being about me and about I
but it's it's him and even though it's
written from the third person it is
absolutely a first-person account from a
battalion commander in combat close
intense combat and let's pick it up
going to the book the clay pigeons of
saint-lo here we go sharp ballistic
cracks pounded his eardrums so rapidly
they seemed like one impossibly
prolonged rifle shot he was instantly
paralyzed with overwhelming fright the
radio operator Jimmy slumped forward at
his feet another man stumbled past to
fall into the ditch ahead then Newcombe
cleared the eight-foot hedgerow
apparently with one jump
but the major was too shocked to move
his stomach nodded itself into a tight
ball it jammed against his pounding
heart while his breath stopped
completely for an instant then came in
jerky gasps the hair on his head felt as
if it were rising like the hair on a
cat's back his skin prickled all over
but the most awful thing was the cold
empty feeling in his guts the burst of
German machine-gun fire lasted only
seconds but it seemed like a lifetime
before he could reach up and snatch a
grenade from his pistol belt he'd never
heard a bullet crack by inches from his
head he didn't know they sounded like
that he thought there was a German with
a burp pistol behind the nearest tree on
top of the hedgerow he grabbed the pin
on the grenade but before he could throw
it something made him stop and yell
anybody on the other side he got a quick
answer hell yes before he could lower
his arm the blast of a rifle right in
his lap made him flinch
he squirmed back even closer against the
hedgerow as Martin and grim cell went
into action they'd been at the front all
11 days since a continuous line had been
established in Normandy the crack of
bullets was nothing new to them almost
side-by-side lying flat in the ditch
they fired methodically across him and
over Jimmy's head mechanically he
checked the pin in the grenade then
still a little dazed hooked it back on
to his belt harnessed he looked at the
man who had fallen in the ditch and now
was trying to weakly push himself up
it was lieutenant Sadler his face
already greenish gray was shocked he had
been hit five or six times in the head
chest and both arms major Jones knew
instinctively that Sadler was as good as
dead he called to him to lie still and
take it easy
but the Charlie Company commander was
already beyond hearing Jones felt that
he ought to do something constructive
something to get their minds off the
tragedy that had just struck but it was
without inspiration merely numb hey you
guys yelled grim zl-- let's scram out of
here that brought the commander out of
the days he'd been in ever since the
deafening burst of enemy fire perhaps
two minutes before he leaned forward and
shook Jimmy's shoulder come on Jim it's
all over now you can get up but Jimmy
didn't move major Jones shook him again
then he saw blood oozing slowly thickly
brightly across his own shoe gently he
pulled a Jimmy's far shoulder a neat
clean little bullet hole in the boys
helmet came into view so the major knew
that Jimmy was dead something impelled
him to pull Jimmy over until he could
look into his face the eyes were closed
and an odd little half-smile made Jimmy
look as if he were asleep dreaming
pleasant dreams
slowly the major lowered him back to the
ground
and for a fleeting instant watch Jimmy's
lifeblood continued to flow across his
shoe so that's his really his first
experience in combat and you can see
obviously it's it's a hell of a wake-up
call
and the whole book the whole book is
like this it's an incredible book the
the way he describes the battles and how
they're laid out and the way he lays out
his own fonts and what's going on it's
just it's it's an excellent outstanding
book and it's one of these books where
as I had to consciously say to myself
okay Jocko you cannot read this whole
book on the podcast we need to you know
people need to read it for themselves
but the book is the description of
combat like that that opening is
phenomenal so let's go back to the book
now where that first battles over and
he's having some thoughts here we go
back to the book as he walked he
couldn't keep his thoughts away from the
hot spot he'd been in a few minutes
before and the lessons he learned so
quickly but it's such a price in little
more than an hour of his first fight he
lost two company commanders to radio
operators and three other men besides
just escaping death himself as he
thought about the crack of those
machine-gun bullets his stomach began to
squirm again until by a conscious effort
he forced it to behave he couldn't
understand why he hadn't been hit to
Jimmy's head had been not more than two
feet from his own new come in the front
and Sadler directly behind him had been
hit
the whole burst must have missed him by
scant inches he decided and he very
seriously thank God for his safety at
the same time he promised never again to
risk the lives of others if he could
avoid it it was a bitter lesson repeated
every time the eyes of his mind focused
on Jimmy's bright blood oozing over
issue or on Sadler's sudden death he
looked down at the shoe shuddered at the
still red stain and tried to scuff it
off on the grass on his way to the
regimental command post
the major passed a knocked out Sherman
tank what distinguished this smoking
brown Hulk from others he had seen that
day was the single blackened claw-like
hand and forearm that was thrust out of
the turret toward the sky the fingers
were separate and more than half curled
like the talent of a striking eagle but
this hand was not striking it seemed
rather to be calling down an imprecation
on the fate that had let it die there in
agony so now he gets to the regimental
commander well boom the regimental
commander what's going on I've just been
trying to get to you
John saluted it as he answered sir we're
stuck at the second hedgerow and I had
to use my reserves to protect my flanks
it doesn't look as if we'll get to La
Forge today unless we have better luck
later have many casualties I don't know
about the companies yet because I
haven't had any reports from them except
the yells about their flanks and
counter-attacks
but NAB was wounded early Sadler is dead
and I've lost two operators besides
three other men out of my own CP group
he was still too full of his experience
not to want to tell about it
the colonel listened sympathetically
well he said when the major was through
we've got to keep going
regardless
Division wants to get the forge tonight
so yeah you said that rough day first
day of combat guess what we're still
going and you know one of the things I
in that opening paragraph that I'd
pointed out was you could see his
reaction when that first gunfight broke
out his reaction was sort of
overwhelming overwhelmed by the whole
scenario but his two guys and what
happened is and you know he talks about
this in the book but he had gone on the
Normandy but he wasn't in charge of a
battalion yet he was sort of back with
the regimental command and then one of
the battalion commanders was out of the
fight and I forget if the battalion
commander was killed or wounded but he
went and took this battalion commanders
job so he wasn't on the real frontlines
until they were starting to push through
France a little bit then it was only a
matter of days but these well I guess it
was 11 days because these guys he said
that these other guys had been on the
frontlines for 11 days so these guys
it's been 11 days but guess what they're
they start getting shot at boom there
and they're in the mode they're
returning fire and you can see the
returning fire really close so close
that it scared him yeah and and that's
one of the things that you know a lot of
times I talk about simunition and
training with simunition and how awesome
it is and that's totally true and I love
training with simunition and it really
is very beneficial for your tactical
skill level but you also absolutely have
to do live fire and the reason you have
to do live fire I mean there's a bunch
of reasons you have to do it you have to
learn to shoot real over bullets and hit
real targets or with your bullets but
also guns are out and you need to
condition yourself to be used to having
a a mark 48 machine gun four inches
maybe not four inches but like 16 inches
from your head and your buddy is dumping
rounds downrange and you have to be able
to think during that and not be
overwhelmed by it yeah the the
simunition this one's an ass like how
what's the difference in loudness this
is not even comparable so is it so it's
not even really like a gun shot no it's
not like
like not comparable it's not the noise
is not comparable the noise is less than
a cap gun oh okay yeah like a airsoft is
my gun is loud and a mark 48 machine gun
it's really loud really now and it any
little shockwaves
yeah everyone is a little shocked with
you get little and so that's why when
that's why it is so important to train
live-fire and it's also important to be
comfortable not only your self shooting
in close proximity with other people but
also them shooting near you because
you've got to trust that you guys it
around you now there's standard
operating procedures that there's things
that you don't do that keep it safe but
it's still I mean when somebody makes
our bet if somebody makes a really bad
mistake they can walk into your field of
fire yeah and so you have to be heads-up
but you still have to take shots with
people that are really close to you yeah
in a firefight by the way well yeah in a
firefight but if you haven't done it
during training your first your first
minute in a firefight is going to be
just just overwhelmed and you knocked me
overwhelmed by enemy fire you to be
overwhelmed by your own guy shooting the
Myriam and you're going to be hitting
getting hit by brass and and just it
hurts
hi Oh Brad yeah ha the wrath and the
links coming out of a mark 48 are like
little weapons itself and they hit your
a bit yeah we had a one of our machine
gunners was a lefty and he picked up and
started shooting he picked up a machine
gun and started shooting left-handed and
that dumps the brass basically right
onto your right bicep and he had a kid
bruise on his on his right arm that
looked like somebody beat him with a
with a baseball bat in the arm that's
what a mark 48 ejector port does to you
it doesn't play around so again going
back to the situation he's in right now
he's he's had all these casualties and
they're like the major says hey yep
regardless we got to keep going
which is which is the way war actually
is
so that night he has a little company
little huddle with the company
commanders and you know just to just to
kind of spell this out if you're
wondering what this is all about so he's
got the he's a battalion commander so
he's actually got this written out in
the book but a battalion of the Italian
in 1944 was about 900 guys 900 men 28
officers you got three companies the
three companies are broken down into
three platoons each one of those
platoons has a platoon leader each one
of the companies has a company commander
you a captain and so that's what he's
talking about so he so that those are
your kind of your hundred and fifty man
fighting elements are these companies
with three platoons in them of fifty
people each about and it's weird because
people always think the military's
everything is perfectly structured but
actually this this changes all the time
not based on but it look based on your
mission you know sometimes you might
have a platoon that needs to get plussed
up or a company that's shorter people so
there's no there's no consistent just
all the time number you see what he says
the actual number that they were
supposed to have in a company at this
time was each rifle company was made up
of six officers and 186 men that's what
they are supposed to have in them now
you're going to find out real quick that
they rarely have even close to a hundred
but that's what they're supposed to have
so at this point he's bringing in these
three company commanders to talk to them
about kind of a plan and also to get a
debrief on on what happened during the
day and what their plan do had here we
go
back to the book he thought a moment and
this is this is a one of the company
commanders named lieutenant Ryan and
he's talking and he says he thought a
moment and then added we might make it
across the road if we pour a lot of
smoke and mortars into him and then rush
him but it'll take but it's getting
awfully late to be beating around in
this kind of country so trying to figure
out how to move forward in lieutenant
Ryan that was kind of lieutenant Ryan
suggestion let's mortar him put a bunch
of smoke out and then we can move but
guess what it's getting late and if
we're running around once it gets dark
it's going to get scary Ryan stopped and
looked at Kenny it was Kenny's turn and
Kenny you're going to find out is a
legit bad
yes sir I only had a few minutes to look
things over before Wendell came along
and invited me back here to see you but
that orchard is a terrible place no
cover anywhere machine-guns covering
every inch of it we lost a lot of men in
there the first time he paused but we'll
do the best we can
well rough or not we're going ahead
the major stated flatly by the way Kenny
just took over for for one of the
company commanders that have been
wounded or killed now they start pushing
and all of a sudden they're pushing
forward and again I have to skip through
this book and I'm trying to highlight
the leadership scenarios or the things
that reveal the way human beings react
in hard situations but when you read
this book yourself you can really follow
the tactical decision-making process and
also how the battles went and what
happened obviously I can't go through
the whole thing right now but at this
point they've started pressing and all
of a sudden he sees guys are running
away running so you know as the company
commander and he talks about this where
he positions himself and obviously
doesn't position himself right on the
front with the platoons he's back a
little bit at this point guys start he
sees guys are running back towards him
at first he thinks it might be Germans
no it's Americans
it's his guys and here we go back to the
book the major got to his feet he
started a crouching run to the left he
had nearly reached the end of the field
when four or five men yelling don't
shoot don't shoot piled over the
hedgerow that separated Charlie and
Baker companies he stopped carbine alert
as he loaded his gun wondering what this
was all about a figure stepped out from
the hedgerow and voiced the same
question what's going on here anyway
just what's this all about
it was lieutenant IP rien arms spread
wide to catch the running men carbine
slung over his soldiers shoulder the
picture of call he caught the leading
man by his jacket which piled the others
up in a tight little not the man pad
panted Krauts paratroopers they're right
behind us run appear e'en glanced over
the
man shoulder unmoved well now I don't
see any crowds just look the men looked
back all they could see were several
Charlie Company men standing quietly
rifles ready the leader of The Runaways
relaxed then shuddered violently aperian
went on I don't think there's any crowds
chasing you at all let's just go see
about this the man tried to pull away
from him
but there were he cried there weren't I
tell you they came right over the hedge
Ville and shot down right down the whole
squad they got the sergeant and all the
rest we're the only ones left they
nearly got me look he poked a finger
through a hole in his jacket but I
period unimpressed moved in the
direction of Baker company even as the
man protested dragging him along while
the others followed meekly well IP Aryan
went on let's just go see what captain
Weddell has to say about that all this
he called softly to the men guarding the
company flank see anything no sir the
answer came back quickly and calmly the
mortar observer and his little group of
panic-stricken men disappeared over the
head row the major knew he had just seen
a wonderful example of leadership at its
very finest IP Rhian quickly calmly and
efficiently had stopped what could have
been a rout so one leader steps out and
really what he's doing if you think
about it
he's detached because he wasn't in that
situation where Germans came over and
obviously shot at a more close range
killed a couple guys when you know what
a would have wounded this soldier who
got shot through his jacket but he just
gets he kind of gets the guy to detach
Hey look there's no one there calm down
let's go have a look let's take a step
back and that kind of calmness prevented
everyone because because what can go in
the other direction right welcome to the
other decks you see people running you
know that's what happens you see people
running you start running you know that
that was very interesting in the in the
I don't remember some of those police
shootings where I remember there's one
in New York City where something like 57
rounds were fired at somebody that was
on
and everyone's going why why was
everyone shooting and I'll tell you what
happens is you know for some reason they
think if you think somebody's has a
weapon or a suspect or is going to do
something bad and now you've got five or
six people that are holding a gun on
them well when one person starts
shooting when people are not attached
and when people are caught up in the
moment and from starts pulling the
trigger and it's it's it can be really
devastating can be really devastating
yeah so wait but when people are used to
that kind of stress and they're calm and
the detached one person takes a shot you
you actually instead of just firing
yourself you actually assess and say
okay what is he shooting at I need to
get cover so there's that's why that
training is so important to get people
at a high stress level and still think
through things and still be detached the
stress is going to be there put it in a
box monitor it don't get in it yeah
because you're going to make bad
decisions you might not make any
decision you might just go off your
reactions which I'm sitting here with a
gun people are shooting I'm going to
shoot - yeah that's not I mean it's like
how you say when you're not trained you
don't have experience in those types of
situations like you're the shooting
example yeah it's it's one of those
things where you see in jiu-jitsu when
you start it's exact literally the exact
same thing right so in a shooting
situation one guy shoots you hear the
gunfire basically your brain just says
okay it's on there it's 100 percent
let's go a full-speed hundred percent
it's on you can't like gun shots are
being fired it's not not on you got to
go hundred percent so in jujitsu when
you first start you know how like the
guys just going full speed the whole
time yeah you're in a spot where it's
like you can't move here you can't
you're completely trapped right here
that's the mission necessarily but
you're trapped that guy's going crazy
you know okay good just because you
don't know it's on it's either on or
it's not on yeah so when you name your
differences though you're what you're
talking about is an individual
individual moment what I'm talking about
is group it's a group think scenario
yeah we're you know just like it happens
when there's a gun shot and everyone
started running people do but the people
the background only
know what the running got people running
in there running yeah yeah sure
well you imagine how amped you are you
think there's a bad guy in a dark alley
and you're there with for your police
partners or your or your your military
partners you're looking down now you
think there's an insurgent there and all
of a sudden around cracks off you're
you're lucky and there's a there's a
situation that happened with it where
there was an Iraqi soldier that had an
accidental discharge you know that is
like we like he was let'slet's in and
Lafe slave splatoon was taken out a
building and I was actually outside the
building you know because we were taking
out multiple buildings but they were in
one building and all of a sudden crack
crack a couple rounds get shot off and
you know what it was actually I'm pretty
sure that it was pretty sure and RuPaul
this is the whole cast of characters I'm
pretty sure and RuPaul was that like the
head of the train or close to the front
of the train in inside that they were
inside this building rounds get fired
and and RuPaul is thinking okay I think
I think I remember Andrew Paul tell me
this in public okay well we're gonna
grenade these we're going to throw frag
grenades into this next room because
people are shooting at us and it was a
guy
another heads up guy a couple feedback
that knew where the gunfire came from
the where it came from was an Iraqi
soldier friendly Iraqi soldier had
cracked off rounds and accidentally
accidentally and you know luckily that
that guy is a great guy of really heads
up guy grabbed him almost killed almost
choked the shit out of him right there
but can you imagine you're clearing a
house where there's suspected insurgent
and all of a sudden rounds are 5 yeah
well now you're but this is the
discipline yeah and and the guys knew
okay they guys didn't all just freaked
out and started shooting the guys were
you know somebody said hey will somebody
grab the person that shot hey that was
an ad okay wrap it back down wind it
down everyone calm you know what I mean
so there's the difference between guys
have been training really well and when
you haven't been through that country
and also luckily that was that didn't
happen on the second night of deployment
we were you know further into the
deployment where guys had been through
it was like we just talked about guys
had guys had been through plenty of
firefights at this point so they weren't
freaked out there was gun shops they
were like okay wait a second where's
this gunshots coming from but that could
have gone really really nasty so train
train realistically all right
at this point and and also just like
some of the other books but we've read
about world war 2 where we've got you
know it's basically movement it's
basically continually moving trying to
take down targets trying to move forward
trying to get through France trying to
get to Berlin that's that's the
situation and it's the same thing here
these guys this these battalions in this
regiment and basically the whole task
force is trying to move from from city
to city or town to town through France
and that's what's going on here so it's
a continual series of attack dig in
attack dig in attack dig in and you know
you can tell from the title the book
what they're going for is this this
final you know some city of saint-lo in
France so at this point there's an
attack that they were getting ready to
go on and he's trying to figure out why
it got canceled and he's talking to the
commander and he says I think I think
you got further from where you started
than anyone else so he's telling these
general Major John's your battalion went
further than anyone else back book in
fact I believe that's why division
cancelled your attack if you've made
LaForge you would have been way out on a
limb and stood a chance of being cut off
major John's elated at their comparative
success was thankful that he had not
renewed the attack and perhaps made
another five hundred or a thousand yards
they would have been out front like clay
pigeons for anyone to knock down it was
the first time he had seen a practical
application of what was popularly known
as the big picture supposedly concocted
for edification of high brass and war
correspondents yet sufficiently vague to
cover a certain amount of air on the
ground so the reason I wanted to call
that out is he's admitting that from his
perspective like why are you stopping my
attack and at this point they had
they've gotten bogged down then they
were ready to go again then they got
back down and now they were read
go and they get told to stop and so his
first reaction kind what do you wait why
are we stopping we've actually got some
momentum right now and then he finds out
that from the big picture the reason
you're not attacking is because you're
too far out I had everyone if you get go
any further you might get surrounded and
cut off now
this is a situation where understanding
why why is so helpful and especially if
you push that all the way down to the
frontline troops and to the frontline
leadership that's out there thinking hey
we finally made some some offensive
progress and we can move and we can
really take it to the enemy and now
you're telling us to stop what is going
on the headquarters is stupid they don't
get it they don't understand actually
they do understand but they need to do a
better job of explaining why so they let
the people know
all right moving on to this next section
here he's checking out kind of his line
now that they're now that they're dug in
a little bit he'd gone to regiment you
know it's really easy to forget that
these guys and I talked about this a bit
but the best type of communications that
they have is when they actually run
wires between different between regiment
between battalions between the companies
they try and run wires because the
radios are fairly temperamental on
whether they work or not so they use
radio as a backup but the primary
communication is is running a wire and
he had just gone back to regiment to
meet face to face because a meeting face
to face is very important and you know
he just comes back up and he asks one of
the company commander well actually I
think it was his ops officer Newcomb he
says hey any news and Newcombe his ops
officer says nope everything's quiet as
a church the s3 looked at the battalion
commander in the Starlight and grinned
as he went on now major you don't have
to concern yourself with everything up
here you just leave the details to us
we're used to looking after them so a
little bit of decentralized commando
worried about a boss when we got this
we're going to be alright
now next day rolls around and here we go
back to the book around ten hundred the
Germans shelled the battalion heavily
but they didn't follow up follow this up
with an attack by eleven hundred the
wounded had all been evacuated
and the wire lines had been relayed to
the regiment the major instructed grim
zl-- to collect all five company
commanders and meet him as soon as
possible at the crossroads of the edge
of the woods from which they had first
attacked it was only a little way from
the regimental command post
to the edge of the woods he got there
well before the others they came up a
few minutes later he missed Newcombe
before he caught the meaning of their
odd manner grim cells set face should
have given him a hint as the S to step
forward saluted very stiffly and said
with visible effort to keep his emotions
under control sir I must report that
captain Newcomb is dead the others look
silently at the ground and tears begin
to stream down the gentle grim cells
face the news struck the major with the
force of a physical blow of all the fine
men he had met since taking command of
the battalion Newcomb had been one of
the very best he was quick willing and
intelligent wise far beyond his 24 25
years he also stared at the ground for a
moment and then asked quietly how did it
happen
Ryan spoke up same sniper same place as
the doc so a doc had been killed earlier
by a sniper one of my men warned nuke to
stay out of that gap in the hedgerow but
he took the steel part of his helmet off
and sat down on it right square in the
gap itself the sergeant who thought the
captain must have gone nuts all of a
sudden was coming after him to drag him
away but too late the sniper got him
right in the temple John Feldmann numb
inside but to dwell on his sorrow
wouldn't help nodding solemnly he
leveled his finger at captain Weddell
you are now lagoon red three but you
we retain command of your company until
we complete the move into these woods
rental equally grave replied yes sir
I have a little news - we kind of
chadwick got half his helmet knocked off
by a burp gun during all that shooting a
while ago he caught either a part of his
helmet or some of the slugs in his arm
he's out but he isn't hurt badly
he'll be back major Jones who had never
met Chadwick merely nodded again it
didn't hurt so much when you didn't know
the man furthermore a wound regardless
of its severity lack the awful finality
of death Chadwicks temporary loss meant
one less officer whereas new comes death
left a hole in his heart although he
knew Webber would probably be a good s3
to Newcombe in the four short days he
had known him had become a friend grim
soul had moved a little way from the
others he was leaning against a tree his
head down in the curve of his arms sobs
shaking his body he and Newcombe and
become close friends for years and had
worked together daily the major spoke to
captain Menzer the headquarters company
commander see the lieutenant grim Zola's
pulled off somewhere where it's quiet
and given a chance to lie down and get
some rest if he objects tell him it's an
order I don't want to see him around any
more today men sir small and dapper
saluted sharply yes sir
I'll look after George all right
these guys are taking casualties at just
an incredible amount and you know you
see a couple things in here that we've
heard before you know you see the major
realizing that that grim zl-- he's done
he needs a break and you know he says
get him off the line get him somewhere
he can take a break and you also see
these guys filling billets and just
getting promoted
you know battlefield promoted the guy
was one of the company commanders
Weddell he becomes the he becomes the
operations officer boom on the spot it's
it's really you can see why this bloke
was one hack words favorite books so now
they're there hold up for a while and
here we go back to book ten days dragged
by while the battalion sat in Boyd of
rattle if the days were sometimes dull
they were rarely uneventful men were
wounded or killed nearly every day by
artillery mortars or the fire from self
prepared it propelled eighty eight's
that could move unseen into positions
from which they could fire into the tops
of trees of the BLA and then pull back
before the artillery men could bring
fire on them those casualties were bad
enough but they were to be expected
there was one incident that the
battalion commander thought they could
have got along very nicely without
regimen had directed that the battalions
erect barbed wire along their whole
front which they did cheerfully but when
a truckload of anti-personnel mines came
down the major looked at them with
misgivings those things were as
dangerous to the people who laid them as
those as they were to the enemy he
thought so he supervised the mine lane
carefully meticulously noting the
location of each mine on a large scale
sketch of the area being mined the day
after all the mines were laid he heard
the flat multiple muffled roar
a landmine that once he ran toward the
sound he got there with the aid men to
watch with sorrow and anger while they
evacuated three men from the middle of
their own minefield one of them was dead
the last litter carried Iberian who
badly hit in the legs with several
fragments did not know how severely he
was hurt the other wounded men
unconscious was being placed on the
medical Jeep when still another litter
came around the corner of the little
farmhouse that stood on the edge of the
woods the man on this litter had his
eyes closed his face twisting horribly
he jerked over he jerked all over
bringing his legs up so hard the eight
men had to hold him down on the litter
the major looking at the man and wonder
asked what's the matter with him da men
were contemptuous ah said one this guy
never got hit by nothing he was in the
hole fifty yards from where it happened
but he started screaming and yelling and
carrying on something awful we thought
he was hit but he ain't got a hole in
him he was like this when we got to him
jon's realized he had just seen his
first case of neuro psychosis commonly
called combat exhaustion or c/e it
wasn't the only one he was to see
so you got that why I guess that's that
friendly fire friendly fire when you hit
one of your own landmines nightmare now
and also you start seeing some some
psychological damage to guys on the
front line and you know that guy's not
gonna be any good
he can't fight he's literally screaming
and jerking around they have to hold him
down
all right now the battalion is going to
move in and take over a whole area from
the 3rd Armored Division and it's in
moving into this area it's got 300
replacements coming in so something
about that but I'm supposed to be 900
people and they're getting 300
replacements so that tells you and again
I am breathing
I'm skipping I'm not even breathing
about not breathing - I'm skipping so
much of the fighting and combat in this
book but it's just going on continuously
and at this point they're going in they
have they already have 300 replacements
so they've had 300 people you know taken
out or or either either wounded or
killed so at this point lieutenant Ryan
s company is on a patrol and they're
going to go set up an outpost into some
pretty pretty rough area and as the
patrols out there here we go
then came the first shots from the
Patrol they're going in well and it
looked for a few seconds as if Ryan was
going to get to his outpost but a flare
of three red star clusters floated up
from the German lines and all hell broke
loose again every kraut gun that had
been used to help stop the 3rd armored
plus probably a few that had come in
late opened up on about a hundred and
fifty yards of eight of the able company
front
it was concentrated thunderous murder
such as no one in the battalion
ever seen before Ryan's line was a
massive seething leaping flame that
looked as if it were fed from below
rather than from an inconceivable
torrent of shells that came on and on
and on the barrage switched suddenly
from the company to the battalion
command post area itself the battalion
commander and his staff hearing the
first whine of the shells dived for the
new command post hole with a huddled
walk while the walls shuttered and dirt
rain down from the roof concussion blew
out the candles but nobody was hurt the
German Gunners switched to see company
for a few rounds then right went right
back to their prime target able company
while they were pounding Kenny's company
a single short call came in over the 300
which is their radio able six is clipped
that meant Ryan had been hit but there
were no details 20 minutes after that
pretty red star cluster went up all was
quiet again except for some moans and
cries for medics that floated back from
able company but at least no German
infantry had come in under fire in the
20 in that 20 minutes the company lost
54 men plus its company commander almost
every man in the Patrol had been caught
above ground and was killed or wounded
while most of the other casualties came
from tree and hedgerow bursts that sent
fragments down into the holes the men of
the command post group gathered around
the hole silently watched the parade of
walking wounded that filed slowly by on
the way to the aid station occasionally
a man would stumble or waver whereupon a
messenger a wire man would jump to help
him every aid man and litter in the
battalion was already up at the able
line and the first litters were not far
behind the walking wounded some of the
victims moaned and a few cried out a
little now and then but most were very
quiet
Jones was glad he could not see their
faces in the dark
the last letter went by with no word
from Ryan Jones was beginning to hope he
hadn't been hurt badly when four men
loomed out of the darkness each carrying
a corner of a blanket Ryan was half
sitting half lying in the makeshift
litter gritting his teeth at the pain of
the wounds in an arm and a leg
they laid the blanket down gently in
front of the major who stripped off his
coat and laid it over the company
commander Ryan managed to work up a
feeble grin it didn't work too good did
it boss
that's you know when you're the company
when you're the battalion commander and
you come up with a plan with a company
commander and you think you've got
everything right and you use fifty four
guys in a company in 20 minutes
and your company commander comes back
and says it didn't go too good did it
boss to have you wait now they do end up
pushing forward to get some ground and
he's out checking and you're gonna find
this out and he talks about it but he
goes forward to find out what's going on
and make sure the guys see him and at
one point he's checking an outpost a
little outpost where they're guarding
this certain area and all the guys in
the group are focused on a tank an old
burned-out tank that's out there in
front of them and he comes up to them
and here we go back to the book John's
pointed to the corner does it take all
three you to watch that tank while the
whole German army could crawl up to
within ten feet of you without knowing
it the sergeant's mouth dropped open god
major I never even thought about it
after they shot at us from the tank last
time
well you better damn straight start
thinking about your flanks if you want
it if you want to end up being able to
think at all I wouldn't give a damn if
they knocked all three you stupid
bastards out but if they got you they'd
have a good chance of getting into the
middle of your company and I wouldn't
like that
now damn you start thinking again you
know what he's detached those guys just
got shot at from those two that tank
they're not worried about their flank
they're worried about that tank another
sniper being in there another machine
gunner sneaking up into it so he's
attached he rolls up and sees hey I see
the gear focused on the tank but you
can't you've got to keep thinking
going back to book orders came down
during the night directing Lagoon read
major John's first battalion 115
Infantry Regiment would relieve lemon
red by midnight of the following day
lemon was code named for the hundred and
sixteenth who's read first battalion was
holding the line to the left where
Lagoon red had hopped off nearly three
weeks before so they're going up to
relieve and and hold the line they're
going up to to take positions and hold
them meeting the commander of this this
group they're taking the place of back
the book the big commander to
introducing himself shook hands all
around then he took a deep breath and
started in on a careful detailed
briefing fellows he said this is a hot
spot I know you've all been in hot lots
of them before but please take my word
for it this one is really hot he paused
and looked at the officers as if to make
sure they were going to take his word
for it then he went on we've got Nazi
paratroopers on the other side of the
hedgerows they're the best that Hitler
has and they know it they don't give us
much rest we don't give them any we have
casualties every day so please do your
best not to cause any more than we have
to take anyway my boys have been here
for two weeks now and they're getting
right touchy so if any of you get
snapped that don't take don't pay
attention to it just go on and they'll
get over it so that this guys guys are
pretty burnout at this point and they do
this they do this turn over and he goes
out and again the turnover happens
there's more combat there's more
casualties and then he's going out but
they had things settled down and he's
going out to check the line and here we
go back to look as usual major John's
asked a number of men how they were
getting along he got a won't answer that
surprise to my sergeant said well sir
everything's okay it's a tough spot but
I figure we're as good as any other
outfit
hold it down and somebody's got to do it
but I sure wish the major would get
around and see us more often does the
men a world of good to see you down here
in the lines the major who had fought he
was getting around about as often as any
battalion commander should we're
seriously concerned because this
sergeant didn't seem to think so
instead of being annoyed he was pleased
that the man had the uncommon guts to
say what he thought whether or not he
was right so there you go
battalion commander instead of getting
all mad this sergeant says something
he's actually thankful he answered okay
Sarge you'll see me around a lot more in
the future
the sergeant saluted sharply whereupon
stone this is new company commander
stone and the major went on stone trying
to stammer out an apology for the brash
sergeant Johns cut him off but not
before stone had volunteered the
statement that he himself thought the
major got around more than any other
battalion commander he'd ever seen the
fact that stone had not seen any
battalion commanders did not escape
Jones who smiled to himself as the
company commander lapsed into an
embarrassed silence on the way back to
battalion he reviewed his own approach
to the problem of leadership he knew
that he must prove himself especially
his courage to every man in the outfit
if he expected to get the maximum from
them he felt that he had done so fairly
effectively as far as seed company was
concerned because he stayed with them
that night for the counter-attack that
had threatened their left flank also his
personal intelligence service told him
that a company had approved the little
battle he and grim soul and Martin had
had with the machine gun that had killed
Jimmy and Sadler so he's got his own
like notice that his personal
intelligence service that means he's not
I've talked about this before with him
you got your own guys that are telling
you what's going on so his own little
guys had told them that a company they
respected him they knew he was going to
get after it back to the book but it was
apparent that this is going to be a
company by company proposition Baker
company didn't seem to be impressed he'd
have to do something about that
now this is just another thing about
leadership there he's on the field phone
and again I talked about how to put
these wires in and he's on a field phone
and he gets done making something happen
on the field phone it puts down the
phone on the table the phone rang before
anyone could say anything
John's picked it up barking red six
that's his callsign
the operators voice came through clearly
are you finished
yes I am he slammed it back on the table
Wendell shook his head you forgot to
ring off major sergeant Wilson gives the
operators hello fail make sure the lines
are clear sergeant Wilson was the acting
Communications Officer the original man
had been killed and Wilson was doing a
fine job
he'd been in for a commission for quite
a while John's picked up the phone and
twisted the crank on the leather case
the operator answered instantly yes sir
what's your name operator private
Henderson sir the voice was a little
uncertain okay private Henderson you
keep doing your job the way you're
supposed to don't mind me if I snap at
you once in a while I'm sorry he
finished he started to lay the phone
down smiled picked it up and added
finished so again you can see he's a guy
that doesn't get all crazy when when you
know when people come to him and say hey
you're supposed to sign off the line I
got to keep these lines open you're not
signing off the line are you done
you see egomaniac leaders do that get
crazy on stupid stuff they're not
following their own rules
now talking about this network talking
about these communications here we go
back to the FISC this network of
communications enabled three men to keep
accurate minute by minute track of all
that was going over on the entire front
covered by nearly six hundred men from
this one spot they could direct the
lives of all those men actors in the
most thrilling and awful drama of all
time so the way that they're doing this
and I should have explained this earlier
is you have the the battalion commander
and he has a small staff of people that
stay with him most of the time his
operations officer his communications
officer his intelligence officer and
what they do is when they get to certain
positions they find a command post a CP
and when they're in the field what they
do is they dig a big giant foxhole and
they make it as good as they can they
put logs over the top of it they put
dirt on top of that or sandbags or
something so they're pretty they they're
trying to get pretty secure in there
from overhead artillery attacks and then
they run wires out to set up
communications with all these all the
company commanders who have their own
little command posts and obviously this
thing isn't permanent because it has to
be mobile because tomorrow night the
next night we might move another
thousand yards or five hundred yards and
then that that foxhole that we drug in
doing us any good anymore but from this
little command post that they set up
there they're running this whole show
now he talks about his decision-making
here back to the book if he made a wrong
decision he could cause men to lose lose
their lives needlessly or if he was
clever or lucky he might by moving a
single squad or platoon or calling for
fire support defeat the enemy and gain
additional glory for the unit all
without moving from his communications
when in a defensive position such as
this then he's talking here about like
some of that drama that happens back to
the book a single rifle shot could mean
the death of a company commander or it
could mean nothing a mortar round might
wipe out an outpost and lay a company
open to a surprise attack or it might
only kick up a little dust and scar a
few trees
volley of all artillery fire could come
through the roof over their heads or it
could burst harmlessly in the fields
outside a burst of fire from the orchard
could mean another Pig because they had
killed some pigs that they follow
hitting me or a full-scale German attack
each sound built up a certain amount of
suspense to greater or lesser degree the
ring of the phone itself built the
tension higher and higher until the
first words that came in would perhaps
screw it even tighter or dispel it
entirely so that's the life that they're
living and just high pressure all the
time but you know you hear a massive
explosion and that's the same thing I
think life was talking about on the
podcast you know Udyr an explosion you
have no idea what it is you don't know
if it's friendly you don't know if it's
a tank round being fired you know if
it's an IUD going off you don't know if
it's a a mortar round impact knee kick
it may be maybe these guys got to a
point where they could tell the
difference but I'll tell you what you
get into urban combat and there's the
sound is refracting off all the
buildings it's hard to tell where it
came from
and it's definitely hard to tell what it
is and by the way the artillery rounds
that hit our waters being used as IEDs
mmm so you don't know what it is yeah
it's really hard to tell but it was
weird - in Ramadi there was constant
gunfire
like you when you went outside you just
hear pop is always out there you know
even if it was even is on the other side
of the city I mean you you can even out
the other side of city but if it was in
downtown Ramadi and we were back at our
base you know we'd go up on the rooftop
of my building and sit there and you
could just want tracers all night you
know the Marines down in the government
Center were getting attacked for the
14th night in a row you know the outpost
the the army soldiers our camp
Corregidor was getting mortared I mean
it was just constantly happening so what
was it where you if it's closer that's
when it's the concern I have yeah
doesn't context in general know just
yeah this the overall context would
for us for me it was like okay you know
you just you just knew that there was
constant fight again Kylie was going on
yes and yeah I mean obviously if it was
closer than the louder it is and the
closer it is the more of a concern yeah
certainly now he talks about again this
is a subject we hear about all the time
the German mortars and Gunners must have
registered too because they had the
exact range of every foot of hedgerow
held by the battalion on the 10th of
July they covered almost every foot of
the hedgerow that sort of gunnery was
rough on the men they never knew in the
first round would fall but once it had
splattered with its flat crash they all
knew that six or maybe a dozen more were
coming each one a little further up or
down the hedgerow when you heard that
first one you pulled the bottom of your
foxhole right up to your belly and
prayed when you heard the second one you
knew whether or not they were coming
your way if they were coming towards you
it got right rough each round was a
little closer and they were so damn
deliberate about it that the waiting was
worth worse than the crash of the shell
itself you lay there and counted the
seconds between the shells until you
knew that the next one was yours the
twenty seconds or so was the longest one
in the world because you never knew if
you were safe until the shell hit it
could hit anywhere outside your hole
even a matter of inches and you were
okay if it hit in the hole with you
you'd never know it of course actually
only a few shells ever made direct hits
on foxholes but some did and nearly
every man had seen a foxhole that had
been hit there was always the little
tail fin section left on the surface and
after the litter bearers had come and
gone
there was only a pool of dark muck to
show that somebody had been in the hole
it happened twice that day so
this one you can know if you quite
followed what's happening these guys are
in a hedgerow so when they're in a
linear position right and the way you
work mortars is you make small
adjustments on them and and the way that
you fire at targets when you don't know
what the distance is you put the first
one is going to be long and then you you
adjust a lot shorter so then you come
back and it's called bracketing so you
you know you might come back five clicks
and then that was now you're now you're
hit in front of the target now you go
back now you go forward again four
clicks it hits a little behind the
target now you come back three two one
and then boom you hit your target on the
mortar thing there's like the actual
tool that kind of welders do your
adjusting the elevation yeah yes so this
is like a little guy up and down a
little dial it's going up and down to
two of them fire at what angle you want
to find that so what you do is when you
shoot a mortar you you the first one you
go long the second one you estimate
short and then you basically can split
the difference between those two now
you're going to be pretty close and like
you work with a legit mortar team and
the third round is going to be moving
the hand a lot on yeah but what are you
saying here is the Germans they already
knew the exact settings for where to put
like a we see movement at this part of
the hedgerow they don't need to take
beta just go there pre-designated said
it yes they can put around right on that
so they kind of figured it out before I
figured out beforehand they know the
exact because watching which you have to
you know the distance yeah you know the
distance that the mortar shoots at a
certain elevation but what they don't
know is if you're trying to shoot it
something that you don't know exactly
where it is well then you have to
estimate the distance which is a little
bit challenging to do now a good sniper
or a good mortarman are gonna be pretty
close you know snipers know that a this
thing they get it down to really you
know how many meters it is and same
thing with a good mortar but but even
that you know when you're talking about
a far distance of 800 thousand meters
you might be off by 50 meters and that's
that you know being off by 50 meters of
the mortar is a big distance not going
to kill the target that you're trying to
hit
but with these Germans at this point
they already have everything measured
and dialed they have a range card is
what we call it a range card means like
I know exactly when you set up in a
position you could have your rangefinder
and you find out what the range and
distance of everything that you're
looking at so you know exactly how far
dust you can dial in your scope boom oh
I see somebody over at that corner that
building that's 832 meters boom crack
remember that game battleship remember
that I do remember that look yeah like
you can't see it but yeah and your I
forgot a little bit it is your basically
your first round is going to be a little
bit if you hit something then you gotta
do like a jaw closed yeah so what the
Germans like I said the Germans had
these things pre-registered and then
what they would do is they would just
drop they would just hit the whole
hedgerow they live down the line and
these guys knew that once the first
round goes it's you're gonna move in
away from me on the hedgerow or toward
me oh yeah yeah and so can you imagine
the the damn pressure when you're
sitting there that first round goes and
now the next round is gonna be further
away from me meaning the Germans are
going to dialing away from me right or
they dialing towards me and then how
many rounds are they going to go because
if they do enough rounds you're you're
going to be all right yeah that's our
you're not there the game that's exactly
what the huh and what's interesting is
those like you said if this if the
mortar hits outside of your foxhole by
an inch you're probably going to be okay
because the mortar blast goes up and out
when it hit the ground if it gets in
your foxhole you're dead
and so there's this this kind of
randomness that you're dealing with all
right going back to the book a little
after this after 1700 general gearheart
came striding through the trees behind
the company post hole he came on serious
business that of giving orders for an
attack if he carried them by himself
they were important gentlemen he said
with the edge to his voice that was
impressive the division attacks tomorrow
at 0 600 all along the line this is the
drive for saint-lo there were few
details of italians what attack
the general would set at zero 600 the
first battalion would advance in a
southwesterly direction with the village
of belfontaine as its initial objective
that was about all there was to it
except for the usual information
concerning artillery support supplies
location of regimental command post and
that sort of thing so pretty pretty
broad orders like 8 is we're going to do
or in fact tomorrow 0 600 the mission is
to get staying low back to the book by
the time the order got down to the
platoon leaders in their part their part
was pretty simple all they in turn had
to say was all right gang let's take the
next hedgerow when the company
commanders had gone the staff discussed
the plan of attack the question
bothering Jones most of all was where to
put the advanced command post group he
wanted to hold casualties to the barest
minimum yet he wanted to be as far
forward as possible so he's talking
about where should he actually position
himself and his small team of the kalian
staff where should they position himself
22 because when we talk about battalion
staff here you talk about a battalion
sack to be pretty big when you're in a
big battalion but this is not a big
group this small group especially
because they've taken so many casualties
back to the book there were a number of
good reasons for this in the first place
keeping the command group close to the
companies made a lot of difference in
communications particularly in this
close wooded country a clump of heavy
trees or a high hedgerow could spell the
margin between having contact and not
having it that was a supreme importance
second if he had this is why I was
talking about keeping the plan simple
because when you start getting split for
people and you can't maintain
communications with them the difference
between not having communications and
having communications is is night and
day it's disaster and success it's
victory and defeat
back to the book second if you had to
move a bog if you had to move to a
bogged down company or to any trouble
spot you wanted to have the shortest
possible distance to go so it wants to
be close enough to have good
communications he also wants to be close
enough that if something's going wrong
you can get
and make things happen third the group
couldn't afford to stay far behind in
any event because they fully expected
the german paratroopers to close in
around them as soon as they started to
advance if the command post group were
too far from the rifle companies it
would have a good chance of getting cut
off and destroyed or captured then there
was always the consideration that the
men like to know that the old man was
not far behind and to see him once in a
while when the stuff was flying around
so these are things he's considering
they're getting ready you know it's now
getting closer to the attack back in the
book the staff was uneasy they didn't
want to turn in they couldn't say why
there had been other nights like this
they all sense that everyone shared
their own nameless fears now they start
their movement suddenly a terrific
firing broke out every German cannon
more ger rifle and machine gun that had
fired around that day cut loose
simultaneously the sound of mortars
coughing on the German side blended with
the scream of incoming shells grim salon
Hoffmann slid down the steps of the hole
before the first rounds hit the phone
rang
major John's grabbed it red 6 charlie
sixer we're catching hell down here with
mortars and artillery I think me I think
there's enemy infantry coming in under
the fire so the idea is cover and move
you you do this as an infantry platoon
or company or battalion you put
suppressive fire so you start launching
mortars at your enemy and then while
they're all taking cover you advance mmm
and so that's what he's talking about he
says I think there's enemy infantry
coming in under the fire stone broke in
the operator having wisely sensed the
crisis and cut him into the circuit so
the other company commander now tunes in
same here major only I know there's
infantry coming in they're already in
the road with us so there's about to get
some his voice and manner were normally
extremely quiet and easygoing
now his tone was strident with urgency
had it been anyone but Julien snowin and
major might have thought it showed near
panic okay the both of you he answered
as calmly as he could
stuffs coming in here to fight him and
keep me informed major Jones doesn't get
excited about stuff very often he says
oh you're getting attacked cool fight
him keep me informed yes that that
that's how you eat yeah now at some
point all the wires that I talked about
that we're so important for
communication the crowd back at the aid
station they had a cat they captured a
guy cried Wendell suddenly he must have
been part of patrol that came through
and caught all our wires hell there
hasn't been enough shells took fairly
falling to cut them all the smart
bastards they even knew when we checked
radios as well so these guys said a
small group of Germans went through the
lines probably right after a radio check
call all the wires yeah that's that's
how you kick off a an attack right you
screw up their communications now at
this point they are this is turning bad
real bad and and this is again there's
so much great information in here and so
such good documentation of the way this
combat takes place but at suffice it to
say at this point I'm skipping forward
they are getting really crushed and they
got mass casualties they are there when
they advance so imagine this remember I
talked about the Germans know exactly
where their mortgages are going to hit
well the Americans will storm forward
and fight hard and get to another
hedgerow when they get to this new
hedgerow where the Germans were where
they just beat the Germans out of there
the Germans have that hedgerow dialed as
well so so now as soon as they get
positioned they start getting immediate
effective fire from mortars
yeah total nightmare and that's what's
happening and at this point they're
completely bogged down and this might be
you don't get to hear a story like this
very often so the regimental executive
Colonel Smith Lieutenant Colonel Smith
shows up so above the chain of command
of the battalion is the regiment and the
the senior person in the regiment is the
colonel the regimental commander and
this is his executive the person one
down from the regimental commander is
this guy we kind of Lieutenant Colonel
Smith and he shows up and here's what he
says
what's the matter Jones why aren't you
getting anywhere Smith gasped miss
cookies gasping he's running into this
position the major point into the bloody
trail does the dead men to the shells
that were savaging the trees and finally
in the direction of the nearby front
from which came the plotting sound of
mortar fire his eyes were lacking their
usual snap and he answered dully they're
too tough Smith blinked several times he
was obviously trying to think of
something to say something that would
inspire this listless battalion
commander to new effort well he finally
brought out you got to get going right
away
regimen has got a move you just got to
get going
Jones shook his head he wasn't having
any not today was all he would say so
we're talking mentally defeated at this
point and even the the regimental
commander coming in or the regimental
executive commander coming in telling
him hey you got to move he just got to
go which is that that encouragement this
reminds me of in jujitsu tournaments you
ever see a coach saying like you got to
get on top yeah you got to do something
you've got to get out of there yeah that
doesn't help me yeah so that's what he's
saying hey you just got to go I'm
getting mortared my guys are getting
mowed down I'm not I can't do it so back
to the book then for some reason both
men looked up the hedgerow toward the
rear colonel McDaniel the new division
chief of staff was riding toward them
oblivious of the fire just as he reached
the command post a volley of four rounds
screamed in the field just beyond the
hedgerow the concussion tumbled him into
the hole with the major and Smith but
McDaniel did not lose his natural
dignity and he was smiling as he said
hello Jones Smith how we doing now yet a
leader coming in that's very calm and
very cool and just got blasted into
their hole by the way yeah and he looks
up smiles and says how we doing Jones
made an effort to perk up a bit but his
voice lacked conviction or forces you
told McDaniel all about the situation
the chief of staff surveyed the scene
weighing it all very carefully before he
answered when he did his tone was
serious and he was not smiling Jones
when you were on maneuvers in Louisiana
or at VMI and while you were studying at
Leavenworth you saw situations where
units had to be sacrificed knowingly in
order to get a job done didn't you the
battalion commander nodded when you saw
those things you probably never thought
very much about them just accepted them
as a matter of course in war didn't you
the major nodded again you never stopped
to think probably that there might come
a time when you and your unit would be
the one that had to be sacrificed to
enable the parent unit to accomplish its
mission the majors eyes were opening
wider as he shook his head well I don't
know for sure but maybe this is that
time I do know that this is the highest
ground on the Corps front and the key to
the entire defense is saying low corks
best expects us to break it and we think
you are the man to do the job at
whatever cost
now don't let us down without another
word he got to his feet and walked back
the way he had come the regimental
executive tagged after him Jones watched
them go suddenly he remembered that the
general what the general had said to him
the day before I'm counting on you
he turned the Weddell who had watched
this little drama with detached interest
Leroy the major said is he squared his
shoulders and pointed to the sinking Sun
take a damn good look at that son old
boy because it's probably the last time
any of us will ever see it let's go
John's never knew later just what he did
the rest of that afternoon and early
evening
he remembered moving around the command
post forward again and he knew that he
had needled the company commanders
unmercifully threatening them or with
relief of their commands begging
pleading anything he could think of that
would work with that individual at that
moment he found that there was a
comparatively weak spot in the German
lines opposite Baker again he badgered
Martin into persuading the artillery to
give him all the fire that he could hit
that spot at one time that meant a lot
of guns when they all fired three rounds
as fast as the Gunners could load them a
hundred yards of german-held hedgerow
went up in flame and smoke and dust
again most of Baker company streamed
across the field and into the gap
blasted by the artillery that took the
heart out of the paratroopers and the
paratroopers he's talking about our
german paratroopers who began to fall
back all along the line it was no route
the Germans retired from their flanking
threat Baker posed having gained a place
in their main line but they fell back
slowly fighting every foot of the way
the tenacious paratroopers slowed the
week weekend battalion again but they
could not stop it entirely the company
commanders and the platoon leaders
together with metallian CEO had thrown
off their apathy taken a second wind and
were not to be denied at dark thanks to
the inspired leadership that had been
provided in a few short minutes by
Colonel McDaniel the German line was
broken beyond repair the battered
American battalion had made 500 bloody
yards as dusk faded into darkness the
firing began to diminish only to flare
briefly again on the left
then it died away into silence can he
called in Kenny called in to say there
had been a light counter-attack on the
left flank
he had easily kicked it off the major
did not ask for permission to halt the
advance he gave orders to dig in for the
night after he was sure the companies
had close contact on their flanks so
there you go that that's that's just an
amazing account of not only of either
ship but if what leadership was capable
of I mean John's was pretty much done
he's literally saying not today they're
too tough and the way that Nick McDaniel
convinces him and explains to him that
you know those times those times when
you were doing exercises and you they'd
sacrifice a unit so they can accomplish
the mission I'm not sure but I think
you're that unit right now and we're
counting on you to get it done
unbelievable
you know that's uh that's one of those
things to work that's where your that's
where you know from a leadership
perspective you are now you know
entering a situation where Duty is going
to be the most important thing to you
and you also know that the mission is
the most important thing you've got it
you've got to put that at the top of
your priorities and you know you're
going to sacrifice guys and it's going
to be a nightmare but the alternative
the alternative is you're not going to
win you're going you're not going to win
that's the alternative is that your team
is not going to be able to achieve this
and and you know at this point in the
war this war was not settled yet by any
stretch this war was not settled and so
to give up ground and start to let the
Germans reorganize and let them start to
gain high ground which is what they were
fighting for here that's not just going
to affect your mind it's going to affect
everybody and so I've said this on the
podcast before the definition of a team
is when the members of the team think
the team is more important than
themselves and that's what you see right
here they realize John's realize
realizes that look we're going to be and
the title the book is clay pigeons you
know a clay pigeon is right yes that's
what you throw up in the air and shoot
ad and it's just it's a sacrificial
piece of clay and that's why the name of
the book is the clay pigeon to say no
because that's in many cases the
situation that they're in
so this is this is different then when
Napoleon says hey if you get told to do
something and it's not smart and you do
it anyways you're culpable John's he
can't say look no this isn't smart he
knows it's the right thing to do he
that's that's the big difference that
I'm trying to get at here this isn't a
guy who's saying look hey we're gonna
charge this machine-gun nest and I'm
gonna lose it
you know half my platoon but it's not
going to make any big deal and I'm a bad
leader because I sacrificed my platoon
for a meaningless machine-gun nest this
is a guy that knows that this objective
is important knows that this high ground
is needed knows that the the success of
this not just this mission but the
success of this hope this whole assaults
on France and there by Germany is riding
on what they're doing now you could
break it down and say well you know that
made they could hold back and they could
wait well what happens when you hold
back and wait do the Germans have me
more reinforcements that they're sending
their way you know what what does that
actually mean and so he is calculated in
his mind you know what we need to do
this for the good of everyone we need to
do this
at one point now fast-forwarding past
some more of that fighting they do a
good job of kind of of they've knocked
out some of the through through some
fierce fighting they've knocked out
they've moved forward and they've hold
up and now they start advancing again
and here we go
back to the book one one well-placed
stubborn hostile machine-gun stop that
flank attack cold so they're attacking
and they get stopped by one well-placed
machine-gun the German gunner got off
got half of a small squad that tried to
rush him through the smoke and the
attackers had to withdraw dragging their
wounded with them mortars and artillery
left the German undamaged rifle grenades
couldn't quite hit the narrow slit
through which he was firing two
grenadiers is trying to take extra
careful aim had also been hit by
concealed German snipers when the major
arrived it looked as though progress had
stopped using the battalion radio to the
rear command post and the artillery
phone from there he adjusted 18
successive rounds from one gun of the
110 field artillery battalion in a vain
attempt to sharp shoot the machine gun
out of the existence but he couldn't hit
it and after each round burst on or near
the hedgerow the enemy would reply with
a derisive burst there was only one
answer a tank and miraculously a tank
appeared so that's what I'm talking
about he tries with there's a one
machine gun that's holding up this
situation he gets on the radio and car
psaltery artillery which is similar to
mortars they're bigger and more powerful
but it's the same thing it's indirect
fire you're putting rounds far up in the
air and then turn through a big arc
that's going thousands and thousands of
feet in some cases in the air and then
coming basically straight down on a
target and it's when I say it's hard to
hit a target Keys fires 18 rounds to try
and hit this machine gun bunker -
machine gun can't stop it can't help it
so he need to tank and miraculously and
and if you don't know anything about my
incredible affection for tanks and for
tankers because of what they were able
to do in the battle Ramadi - not only
for themselves but to support and save
my guys time and time again I'm a big
fan of Tanks fact I love tanks ten
tankers just straight up that's the way
it is and this is why this is why right
here back to the book one steel monster
monster lumbered up behind Jon's who
yelled instructions to the tank
commander the gunner watched carefully
while an infantry squad leader fired a
clip of tracer bullets at the slit that
hid the machine gun and then swung a
shortboard barreled little 75 into line
it crashed once and almost
simultaneously with the muzzle blast
came the crack of white phosphorus shell
as it hit the slit the smoke blossomed
up from behind a hedgerow indicating a
direct hit with that a single
paratrooper came running toward them a
few moments later everything on the
front cut loose the enemy and the
company charged and another hundred
yards of French real estate had changed
hands then in the major the major wished
every machine gunner and his outfit
could have seen that position as an
illustration of what skill tenacity and
guts could do to build and defend one
machine gun position so machine gunners
tanks
yeah it's credible what a machine I mean
even you know the machine gun is right
I mean machine gun there I mean uh
normal like a mark 48 machine gunner the
old m60 Roger Hayden talked about
carrying the 60 right and in our boys
last to point my last deployment Ramadi
guys are carrying mark 48 or mark 46
which is a smaller round of five five
six round m60
that's what Rambo had right that is no
one has yes yes and commando by the way
first
okay I'll take your words out a matrix
to be exact knows is me okay be m60 sure
the Bello said machine gun tell yeah
they're not that big of a weapon I mean
it's big and blood should believe me
when you're carrying 800 mm rounds it's
big enough but if you think about a
whole you know a battalion worth of guys
are getting stopped by a guy in a
machine gun yeah yeah good position now
he had snipers snipers covering him -
snipers apparently were covering him but
that's that's that's not many people
that's why when you're on the offense
you need more people than being in a
defense position you know ad even when
you're in a defend defensive position
and you're allowed to use time to set up
that's why when you go back to what when
you look at normally we look at this
hole if you look at world war ii as a
whole the both the the Allies and what
we did in in Normandy
taking the beaches and what you did
every time in a Pacific taking the
beaches you're going against bunkered
positions like this yeah and it's just
incredible the tenacity that it takes to
make this happen
yeah it isn't that the whole in a way
the whole idea behind guerrilla warfare
where it's like we're just we're kind of
we're not fighting without fighting and
then all of our fighting and then we're
not for that that is that that is behind
a guerrilla warfare but this isn't
guerrilla warfare yeah even without the
even without sneaking around right right
you got your the uniform soldier German
and you go okay I'm going to set up a
bunker position on this high ground
eight where I have the enemy channelized
in this area and I have good spread on
them and the only weak spots I've got
I'm recovering with snipers yeah three
people holding up a battalion
and just think you know if then once you
get that position we have mortars
already dialed in when you get there
that are going to start hitting you and
then the next thing you do is you've got
to move again well guess what we got
another three four five guys in machine
gun positions new to supporting each
other that's why this this these
American allied fighting forces and the
Americans here and the Americans in the
Pacific going against hardened bunkered
positions is incredible it's incredible
now he's given kind of an overview of
war and and here we go
thus goes battle a rush a pause some
creeping a few isolated shots here and
there some artillery fire some orders
some smoke more creeping another pause
dead silence more firing a great
concentration of fire followed by a
concerted rush then the whole process
starts all over again the defender this
is just as good information the defender
will almost always hold out some reserve
even though his front line is being torn
to bits
at least he should he may inflict all
the damage on the attacker that he can
while giving ground slowly then when he
thinks the attacker is weakening or when
the defense has reached a certain piece
of ground that the defender has chosen
for the purpose he launches a
counter-attack with his reserves the
attacker has used much of his strength
his men are tired probably short of
ammunition and are almost inevitably
somewhat disorganized then the defender
throws fresh troops into a
counter-attack over ground his men know
unless the attackers are very strong
they must inevitably suffer often then
they are defeated and thrown back or
destroyed so there you go I mean this
happens and mixed martial arts it
happens in sports it happens on the
battlefield these guys are pushing
forward on the attack and you take away
leave you chip away at them a little bit
you give them ground you give them
ground and then when they when they get
spread out they're low on ammunition
boom then you hit him on a
counter-attack on the ground that you
already know back to the book such
counter-attack tactics have been
standard almost as long as there have
been organized armies the Germans
employed them so regularly that they
were never a surprise but the inner
enemy could never muster seem to muster
the strength necessary to make their
counter-attack stick their efforts often
halted in advance as they had the night
before but they rarely gained back any
ground and were almost always costly to
the counter attackers even the best and
most proven tactics still require
judgment and the force to do the job the
Germans rarely
enough of either so there's a little
breakdown on what's happening with the
Germans first of all they're not using a
judgement they're just like standard
operating procedure we're going to
counter-attack every single time and we
counter Zac you're taking losses
especially for not gaining ground so
their standard operating procedure we're
in a counter-attack and they're not
gaining ground and so what they doing
they're losing guys and the more guys
you lose the less guys you have to
counter-attack with for the next time
yeah now they had a they had a group
here that was working in the battalion
they were called the commandos it was
just like a little elite group that they
were using they would guard the command
post but then they would also when
someone's going down they'd get out
there and after super aggressive but
they were running so low on people that
they needed to put the commandos team
back out into the companies the regular
companies so there have been a little
commando you in a little special unit
within the battalion and then they had
to take those guys and put them back out
with the with the regular companies now
here we go back to the book in the
middle of the afternoon the CEO moved up
close behind a company to watch their
contingent of former battalion commandos
go into the line sergeant Turner who had
made it who had been in charge of the
platoon of the commando platoon was with
them seeing the major he fell behind
long enough to say sir we're going in
there to help our buddies from old a
company linked the hell out of those
bastards but when we get through this
I'd sure like to come back and get
another bunch of commandos for the
battalion his cool voice ended on a
rising note alright sergeant you get us
into saint-lo and I'll promise you you
get another platoon of your hellraisers
just as soon as we can spare them from
the company's John's return to the
sergeants John's returned the sergeant
salutes and watched the man as he ran to
catch up with the others an hour later a
weasel which is a small purpose tracked
vehicle flying a Red Cross flag
clattered out of the woods carrying a
load of wounded on litters the battalion
commander who is
passing the spot stops when he saw the
wounded the little commando sergeant lay
on the litter on the near side seeing
the major he yelled for the driver to
stop Jones went over to him and the boy
both his legs wrapped in dirty bloody
bandages grabbed his commanders shirt
and pulled himself up on the litter he
was crying openly and unashamedly as he
burst out with a flood of invective they
got all my boys nature we didn't get off
the LD which is the line of departure I
let you down major I let you down he
stopped and sobbed bitterly before he
could go on major Jones could feel his
own throat constricting as he held the
tightly gripping hands that shook him
again and again as the sergeant poured
out his grief and rage and
disappointment we had to get that gun
damn the dirty bastards god damn god
damn I let him get me with a fucking
machine gun and they got all my boys to
goddamn he sobbed uncontrollably while
the weasel driver began to let his
clutch take hold but I'll be back major
sir I'll be back I'll be back sure boy
and I'll have your old job for you
anytime you just take it easy and get
those legs fixed the major was walking
slowly beside the litter trying to
gently disengage the grip on his shirt
the sergeant let go and fell back on the
litter exhausted Jones looked up at the
aid man who slowly shook his head the
sergeant would not be back
now they are finally pushing into
saint-lo and and they have to go down
this or the direction of attack that
they're taking is down this down this
single road that heads into saint-lo
and the germans have it dialed they have
it dialed with range you know with
artillery ready to hit it and here we go
and they have hit they're starting to
hit it with big rounds back to the book
John's noted that the German fire was
coming in slowly there couldn't have
been more than two or three guns firing
as they were all big ones they didn't
fire rapidly that was a break but just
one of those big shells in the wrong
place as the next one began to howl the
men began to look for deeper spots in
the ditches John's yelled keep going
dammit it's not here yet the men kept
going forward for several more seconds
running hard now the shell was nearly on
the ground before the major yelled again
down although the men hit the ditches
John was too excited to remember he was
in the middle of the road he went down
on one knee the shell burst a hundred
yards ahead
again nobody was hit the instant burst
the major was up yelling let's go
running as he yelled his men got up and
ran to Hoffman and Griezmann a grim cell
catching the idea moved further back
down the line of men to relay commands
and call signals on the shells when the
next one hit all three officers did the
same none of them got off the road here
and there non comms without orders began
to fill in the gap staying on the road
themselves by the time the third shell
hit the whole column was working as
smoothly as if it had been on a parade
ground drill and they were losing no
time they kept going a few men were hit
but not many
oddly oddly enough not an officer or
noncom was knocked out of the middle of
the road though each leader only went
down on one knee
one shell burst not
twenty four five yards ahead of the
major but it hit just around a small
bend in the road and he was sheltered by
the bank he ran forward through the
smoke and dust nearly falling over a man
who is rolling crazily half in and half
out of the ditch
John's grabbed him by the arm to help
him to his feet crying come on boy let's
go the man tried to get up but stumbled
awkwardly forward only then did John's
look down and see that the soldier had
no feet he was trying valiantly to stand
on the stumps of his two legs where his
feet had been sliced cleanly off just at
the ankles
John's laid him back gently into the
ditch and changed his tone maybe you
better take it easy wild son you stay
here until one of your buddies gets here
they'll be along in a minute
the man himself was an aid man and not
another was in sight but the battalion
commander had no time for one man so
after a quick look to see that the
stumps were not bleeding profusely he
patted the man on the back saying see
you later bud then he ran to catch up to
his place in the column a little further
down the road after another burst he saw
another man lying in the ditch not
making any move to get up and go
although he didn't seem to be hurt John
stopped grabbed him by the arm and
yelled again come on let's get going
looking blankly up at him the soldier
pushed a camera forward saying
plaintively I'm a cameraman this rocked
the major for a moment then he said well
you can't take any pictures in that
ditch get going
so again you see leadership in action
you see him having to actually lead and
set the example and his other the
company commanders and eventually the
the senior enlisted guys all follow his
lead of what he's doing
we got time to run we got a minute or
whatever it is 30 seconds we're going to
get up we're going to run as hard as we
can when we know we're going to get hit
with a shell we're going to get down and
take cover
pure leadership now once they get kind
of into saint-lo there's a colonel shows
up starts getting told what to do back
to the book the Colonel's giving orders
again I want you to clear this town as
quickly as you can
there aren't many Germans in it but
there are a few and I wanted all clear
your battalion is the only infantry we
have with the task force as you are the
ranking officer you will be in command
of all the troops in town they look
closely at the major who nodded trying
to contain the elation he felt knowing
that he would have command on the ground
of what would undoubtedly be a
historical action the Colonel thrust a
map at him here's a large scale map of
the town itself now get going Major
John's turn to look for Wendell Wendell
and Graham cyl his two staff officers
turned company commanders both were
almost at his elbow he drew them to one
side and divided the town between them
so now they're kinda on the outskirts of
saint-lo and they're starting to clear
the town and we have sudden the
companies go out and start clearing the
town and they've set up a little
makeshift command post for four major
John's and and he's standing there if
he's got he's got a bunch of new guys
with him too he's got all these
replacements because remember an hour
and a half ago when I said hey these
guys have already had 300 replacements
all that has kept up the whole time
they're getting all these replacements
so at this point this is an interesting
leadership story here he's got some new
guys that show up and there's he's
standing in his new command post and
these new guys he sees like a position
that needs to be taken to make sure that
you know we have some security around
the command post and so here we go he
motion to the
FC and three other men standing nearby
they came forward rifles ready so these
are three new guys just replacements
just showed up
and again the probably the most fire
they've seen was running into the town
of st. Louis howitzer shells that are
hitting them back to the book see that
alley there said John's pointing I want
you to take these three men and go down
to the end of it looks like about a
hundred yards where you will set up an
outpost
lieutenant liquor II will come around
later to see how you're doing the PFC
squinted down the alley nodded a trifle
uncertainly and started toward it the
others followed but the major was too
preoccupied to note there been no
briefing and no assignment of positions
or duties they just tripped off down the
alley together like a bunch of men going
to the post exchange two minutes after
they left the sound of German
machine-gun fire came from the direction
of the narrow passageway John's turned
to look out of the alley pelted the four
men straight toward him the private
first class panted sir there's a machine
gun down there the battalion commander
didn't know whether to be amused or
angry there was no telling what the new
men were apt to do if they didn't have
leadership of an experienced or
well-trained non-common officer he
decided to be gentle yes I heard it now
tell you what to do you take these three
men again assign one to take a place
where he can shoot at the gun or where
you think the gun is then take the other
two and see if you can't come around
behind it and get it for me so little
cover and move there's a real simple
look of remove you you get blue you can
shoot the gun have that guy get where
you can shoot the gun and then you guys
maneuver behind cover move beautiful the
PFC took that in nodded somewhat less
uncertainty motion to the men to follow
him and started purposefully back down
the alley and not more than five minutes
there came in rapid succession the sound
of the machine gun a few rifle shots two
grenades and running feet John's had
moved across the street looking for the
best place for a temporary command post
he turned toward the mouth of the alley
wondering what would come out this time
two Germans showed first running toward
him
full speed before the major could bring
a submachine gun up he saw the PFC and
one other man robbing the Germans from
behind with bayonets they spotted him
and poked the prisoner in his direction
they stopped in front of him before he
noticed the mg34 the PFC was dragging
behind him so they actually had the
German machine gun the man dropped the
gun in front of him saying here's the
gun you wanted major but this is all
that's left of the crew we had to kill
two of them sir major Jones gulped
nodded and motion to gay was another one
of the guys to come to get the prisoners
the private first class and his helpers
jogged back toward their new outpost the
major looked after them wondering just
what sort of training or indoctrination
they must have had first to run away
from an enemy without trying to fight
back and then to apologise for having
killed - he looked down at the German
that the battered German machine-gun
kicked it idly and reminded himself to
be more careful in issuing orders to new
men they were apt to take things a bit
on the literal side he was sure that the
PFC had actually thought that the seal
himself had a personal desire for the
machine-gun they had knocked out and
they we've gone to any ends to retrieve
the gun itself in order to bring it back
just because the major had added that
for me when he ordered them to get the
gun yet that's like a common thing to
kind of add right like in you know how
back when he work at the nightclub you'd
hear that all the time like it look
especially when you're managing big
crowds so you say hey can you you know
can you slide over on the side here for
me and they'd always add the for me I
always thought like that's kind of
strange thing - I mean it's so common so
but when you really think about is like
- kind of strange thing to add but I
think it like adds like this personal
touch it was like a little too personal
yeah I'll drop out all right now he's in
the command post wet was one of the
company commanders these guys were out
clear in the city and he hears some
commotion comes back into one of the
room
and lentils in there with one of the
other officers or one of the other
officers been working on him back to the
Brooks sobbing was carefully cutting
away the officers field jacket and shirt
exposing a wide deep gash just below the
shoulder Jon's stomach turned over
quickly when he saw the wound the bone
was shattered with sharp splintered end
sticking through the bloody pulpy
massive torn flesh that's this is
Weddell he's talking about lentil was
damn near right they'd almost blowed his
arm plumb off the s3 moaned closed his
eyes as he leaned back to let Brooks
duty could with the nasty wound but he
pulled himself together in a moment or
two and opened his eyes to look at the
seal so he Ria's Reynolds just in agony
but he gets gets a grip then he looks at
the seal squeezes his eyes together hard
then looks at the CEO and says I was
just coming back to tell you
he drowned out between clenched teeth
that we have our side of the townhall
career with the man out on the edge when
the artillery caught me in the middle of
the street he flinched his face twisted
in pain when the aid man who had taken
over from books inadvertently twisted
his arm as he sprinted soulful powder
into the wound then he went on Chadwick
is back didn't know it until I saw him
came up just came just before we pulled
out out of the little road back up the
hill you can put him in command he's
good he was gasping at the words now
major can you get me out of here I don't
want to lose this arm sure boy we'll get
you out just try to relax now don't
worry about it
take it easy and we'll have you back to
where they can fix it up in no time
Weddell leaned heavily on Brooks who is
still sobbing from the shock of seeing
his captain so badly wounded
Wetteland Brooks had been together a
long time and major new the sergeant
would be no good around the command post
for a while so he motioned him to go
along and look after the wounded s3 so
again you know major Jones realizes that
somebody's at their capacity for
handling the horrors of war and says hey
you take this guy back to the aid
station now there's a German
counter-attack so they're in st. lo the
god thing is decently handled but all of
a sudden they start seeing and there's a
guy in the field named Barnes he started
to report back hey they're they're
forming up a big counter-attack and also
their field phones are been they lost
wires so they're going to have good
communications they see this thing
forming up there's going to be overwhelm
they're really undermanned saint-lo is a
pretty big city it's all kind of
destroyed but it's still too big for the
amount of people that they have and so
they're really scared that there's going
to be a big counter-attack the generals
going to take the city back so they
finally get through they don't even know
who they're talking to they're just
trying to get through to somebody that
can password to get the artillery to
start dropping bombs and Henderson is
one of the guys on the on the radio and
he says damn it man this is the goon
read in st. Louis worsen that ever
needed anything in all our lives and we
need it right now
all our lines our rear all our lines to
the rear are out and our wire people
spliced one and got you now quit asking
damn fool questions and tell me if you
can shoot for us insane low so this is
going back and forth they start dropping
bombs and all of a sudden they start
adjusting the bombing closer and closer
to them to their own lines
back to the book angel fire direction
Center was questioning the adjustment
the correction would bring the shells
inside the no fire line maybe on
friendly troops hell yes we got dough's
on the edge of town who do you think
wants this stuff anyways the artillery
man was frantic afraid of the safety
rules the big guns would make them stop
them just when they needed the most
please sir he pleaded just put it out
there the
the tree battalion commander is standing
right beside me praying for more of it
the last volley was right in there but
the Germans are still coming they stand
to get him to drop more bombs and bars
the guys out in the field calls back in
again that was marvelous do it again
some more and then the guys transferring
that repeat range fire for effect give
us all you have and give it quick you're
breaking up the attack and you're all we
have and that's enough
that's that they bomb the bejesus out of
the Germans and that pretty much brakes
the attack and again I'm summing up like
seven pages of extended combat and
finally though the the battle is for the
most part over and they've got
stabilized they kind of set some
security and here we go back to the book
major Jones his face in his hands as he
sat down for the first time in hours he
couldn't help thinking of the death and
agony to so many men so needlessly
they'd hurt damnably deep inside
and then a liaison officer from regiment
came in with a lieutenant colonel his
staff and all of his company commanders
they were from the hundred and thirty
fourth regiment of the 35th division
which was to relieve the first battalion
at once Jones could hardly believe it
even when he saw his replacement
standing there looking fresh and
confident he was beginning to think the
clay pigeons were supposed to go on
forever fighting all alone except for
the artillery the new battalion
commander wondered about major stat
Major John staff so he's got a guy
coming in to take over there getting
relieved and the guy says you know hey
what's up where's your battalion staff
back to the book Jones explained and as
he did he reviewed in his mind all that
had happened in the short thirty days
since the first attack and the boy
dobrze tell his whole forward staff was
gone Newcombe Sadler Carter and McCarthy
dead Weddell and Hoffman wounded grim
sell-out commanding a company nabbed
Ryan Todd stoan Cordy AK Kenny and
Dettman all wounded besides God knew how
many other officers he had never even
known by name the company commanders
from four companies
killed or wounded mostly in the space of
seven short action-packed days he
stopped talking while he thought for a
moment of all those fine people when he
glanced up catching himself he thought
he was looking at a ghost there stood
Kenny the shadow on his face wavering as
the candle flickered and the faint
breeze of his entry so Kenny had been
wounded and now he's back in an instant
his troubles preoccupation with her with
the relieving officers were forgotten
Kenny he cried what in God's name are
you doing here well major I heard you
got into town alright but were sort of
short of company commanders I saw Todd
Dettman and Cordy ACK back there so I
thought I'd better get on up here and
see if I could do anything
the docs will let you go these days if
you can stand up straight for two
minutes without falling down
the major saw that Kenny was exhausted
in spite of his cheerful attitude he
found out later that he had walked alone
in the dark all the way from the
division clearing station several miles
to the rear in order to get back to the
battalion his legs and back were covered
with bandages under his new shirt and
pants he said well old man there isn't
anything you can do right now these nice
people have just come in so we're going
to be out of this rat trap in a little
while you just go back behind mrs.
Blanchette here and lie down and get
some rest you need it Kenny did as he
was told the strain had begun to bend
even his indomitable will at zero for 40
the major reported the regiment that the
hundred and 34th Infantry had taken over
the wireman took out the phone the major
shook hands and said goodbye and good
luck to the new arrivals then he and
Kenny followed the companies down the
hill just seven days ago they had
numbered 800 they were now only 450
proud tired men the clay pigeons who had
taken the core objective
clay pigeons and from Omaha Beach to the
Elbe the first Battalion 115 infantry
29th division had two thousand three
hundred and eighty four casualties
including four hundred and fifty-four
men killed in action so that that's
that's hard to even fathom again think
about the fact that at this time a
battalion was about it's supposed to be
about nine hundred men and they'd taken
two thousand three hundred and eighty
four casualties so all the replacements
that came and kept getting wounded
unbelievable and what's I mean that you
got to read this book and get the
lessons learned in and also you get
lessons learned from that book but you
can also get some of major John's lesson
learned from colonel david hackworth in
his book about face and what's you want
to talk about some layers some some
historical layers to check this out so
in about face
you know hackworth talks about what
happens in august 13th 1961 the
communists in berlin that started
stringing barbed wire and they were now
going to build a wall between East and
West Berlin and then you know Kennedy
whose president wanted to do something
like you can't just you know we need we
need to make some kind of a statement
here so he sent 1,500 soldiers from the
first battle group of the 8th Infantry
Division and they were selected
apparently by Kennedy by name
so Kennedy said I want these guys and
the reason is because their commander
was a guy named Glover s Jones and he
wanted them to go and reinforce the
British French and American troops who
were on the ground in Berlin and then
layers Colonel John's in his position
appointed D Company in his battle group
he'd be pointed D company to be the
battle groups reaction force and who was
the commander of D Company it was a
young Korean War veteran who had come
back into the army named captain at the
time david hackworth and as I said pak
worth points to Glover Jones as his
primary source for leadership lessons
learned and he captured them coming
succinctly from Glover Jones himself in
about-face so let's take it back to that
book for a minute here from about face
all too soon Colonel Jones received
orders back to Berlin as chief of
intelligence so now this whole thing
that they'd gone through with sending
this this force to reinforce the French
British and American troops on the
ground in Berlin this is pretty much
done all through soon Colonel Jones
received orders back to Berlin as chief
of intelligence most of us had known the
magic couldn't last forever but it
didn't change the fact that we were
incredibly sad to see him go
on 15 January 1962 the battle group fell
out smartly for its final review before
our favorite soldier the weather was
bitterly cold but no one noticed we were
all too busy standing tall and greedy
soaking in the Colonel's farewell
address
Jones's a leader who taught by example
some
the points he made weren't exactly new
to us but to hear it in a single speech
this great man's basic philosophy of
soldiering was like being led on letting
in on the secret ingredients of some
magical formula to wit strive to do
small thing as well be a doer and a
self-starter aggressiveness and
initiative are two most admired
qualities in a leader but you also must
put your feet up and think so there's a
little dichotomy he's hitting on yeah
you got to be aggressive but you got to
think strive for self-improvement
through constant self-evaluation yeah be
humble never be satisfied ask of any
project how can it be done better don't
over inspector over supervise allow your
leaders to make mistakes in training so
they can profit from the errors and not
make them in combat decentralized
command key patru informed telling them
what how and why builds their confidence
the harder the training the more the
troops will brag boom remember that guy
to ask last podcast how do i improve the
morale of a group get them get them to
have pride train hard next enthusiasm
fairness and moral and physical courage
four of the most important aspects of
leadership enthusiasm fairness and moral
and physical courage next showmanship a
vital technique of leadership that's
interesting and there's a bunch of in
about face hackworth he specifies some
of these things that he would that
that Glover Jones would do showmanship
wise he walked down the range and he was
a really good shot the rifle and
apparently he have a guy throw a quarter
like a coin up in the air and he'd shoot
it because he was such a good shot that
and another thing he did he's about to
give a speech somewhere and in sort of a
mixed audience but a bunch of German um
sort of political people
Glover Jones gets up and just gives the
speech in German alright next the
ability to speak and write well two
essential tools of leadership boom next
there is a salient difference between
profanity and obscenity while a leader
employs profanity tempered with
discretion he never uses obscenities
next have consideration for others hmm
next yelling the tracks from your
dignity take your meta side and counsel
them next understand and use judgment
know when to stop fighting for something
you believe is right discuss and argue
your point of view until a decision is
made and then support the decision
wholeheartedly last stay ahead of your
boss when John's had finished
Colonel couch TV order to pass in review
and company by company we marched by
with just that little extra precision
our shoes uniforms and brass earlier
attended to to provide just that little
extra Sparkle as was the custom the
company commanders peeled off after the
unit's past in the review stand and
congregated for final goodbyes John's
had watched the parade with tears in his
eyes
the tears remained as he stood at
attention so tears in his eyes that is
Major Glover Jones that is the clay
pigeons that is the first Battalion
hundred and fifteen temperature 29th
division and obviously he is an example
of leadership and the men of his
battalion the clay pigeons they are yet
another example of the indomitable
warrior spirit and culture that is the
very core of this nation don't forget
that
don't forget that culture don't ever
forget it and for those of you out there
right now defending our nation that
spirit and that culture it can work to
hold you up and having it in your brain
can keep you strong in trying times but
there's also a dichotomy there because
not only does that warrior spirit and
warrior culture hold you up you also
have to hold it up you have to maintain
that warrior culture in the way you
think and then the way you act and if
you ever start to forget how you're
supposed to think and how you're
supposed to act then remember Colonel
Glover Jones and the clay pigeons say
hello
and I think that's all I've got for
tonight echo Charles yes so I guess
speaking of maintaining yes maybe you
could tell us how we could maintain
support of this podcast if you if you
want if they want and for ourselves
hey what is fire for effect in Ferris
releases awesome so you're on radio yeah
and you're watching your calling
auxilary or you're calling a naval
gunfire or you're calling air support
and you're trying to get them to hit
this target whatever that target might
be that's are trying to get in to hit a
building where they're smooshed and they
get a direct hit but now you say fire
for effect
yeah that means you'll need to make any
more adjustments you can just start
hammering that's a boom boom boom boom
perfect good so when somebody does on
it's on target you like a fire first or
I gotcha oh dang okay I think it is
that's one of those ones that you know I
adhere oh you and life always say it and
you know certain do we know how much no
no not that one but that's where I would
hear it I hear it kind of come out oh
and you know how certain terms if you're
not familiar with them you can kind of
gather what it means yeah you know in a
contact the commas run in the words and
stuff like that but that one I I never
could really figure out exactly what
that means as opposed to you know modern
I'll fire at will or you know all these
other things that you hear yeah fire for
effect fire Perfector they would it kind
of sounds like it could mean like to
distract them or something to have some
effect other than here in the target
area I like that yeah apparently not
apparently it's the opposite and so good
yeah they did amazing you sure hope
these these guys man yeah in and I'm
telling you like and I've said this
before that thread of and I actually
don't like using the word or your
culture yeah
because because it's so
although reuses yeah man it's so
overused and it's late just it's it's
been so degraded just by these horrible
meaningless things like as a warrior you
know what I mean because he you know
deactivated the crime and actually
survived his prison term yeah it was
reward warrior no you're not
yeah you know different but but there's
no other word that I can put on it at
least that I could think of right now
when you talk about
the American culture and it's so easy
because America is a big place mmm and
America has got a lot of good things
going for it and a lot like you know the
culture of art of art in America's
massive yeah the culture of music is is
unbelievably powerful here the culture
of Education and academia all these
things are massive in America right and
n it's really easy to forget the culture
this the most in my mind the most
powerful culture that we have now I
could be wrong I mean what about our
arch put on trippin Oriole spirit and
culture right that's huge here very
strong our capitalist culture we want to
make money we want to grow we want to do
things right those are all really really
powerful and I think we tend to forget
we tend to forget we want to we want to
say that you know the Japanese Bushido
culture is this thing we should look up
to guess what that's what that Bushido
culture versus the US Marines the you
know storming beaches in heavily
defended beaches another guess what if
the American warrior culture that's
that's the real deal yeah that's the
real deal the Nazis oh the stormtroopers
oh yeah those are such a warrior culture
guess what compare them to these guys
yeah
no not happening sorry yeah yeah these
in his a lot like that there was a
little part
the book where the guy got his legs
blown off something like that and he was
like I'll be back yeah I'll be like
teasing and it really seemed like he was
you wasn't pissed about his legs he was
pissed that he's out of the game feels
like I'm like guys down I'm good you
know yeah I think a lot of times and you
know America is kind of wanted in
example where you know once all things
are going real good it's easy to point
out the things that are not going but
you know like here whatever the case may
be like when if everything's perfect the
little imperfections show themselves
more you know like if your life is like
everything's together work yeah I know
your job is good and your family good or
whatever but meanwhile like you're out
about your front lawn is going down
you're like my front lawn is going by
you know is like that kind of thing I
think that's what we have in the u.s.
it's kind of like we things are real
ideas I think it's more just a matter of
percentage I mean I think in America
right now it's like a 1% of the
population is actually in the military I
mean all these World War two veterans
not many of them left Vietnam veterans
are getting older
Korean veniat veterans are very very
rare at this point so and what are our
movies about you know instead of making
movies about saint-lo they make movies
about the aliens attacking or whatever
yeah you know so we just it's pretty
easy to forget that the reason we're
here and the reason we're not speaking
German is only reason we're not speaking
Japanese is because of this warrior
culture here which kind of it's right up
there yeah it's right up you show me any
warrior culture that has the same that
you know I know there's equivalents I
know there's other I know there's other
military units in the world and other
countries that have a proud military
tradition as well but you know obviously
I'm biased towards mine yeah but uh you
tell me any historical unit that you say
oh these guys were the Spartans and they
were the real warriors right you know
you haven't really spent much time with
a 19 year old Marine yeah you you
haven't spent much time with a with it
with with a soldier from an Airborne
you just you just you gotta meet those
guys yeah I'm telling you they're the
real deal
yeah and no matter what kind of you know
historical warrior you want you want to
throw out there I'll put my Americans
against the head-to-head it just the
terms that just straight-up warrior
culture and spirit yeah I'll go I'll go
toe-to-toe I'll go toe-to-toe for sure
I'm not I'm not trying to say we're
better yeah but I will toe to toe with
the Spartans yeah I will toe to toe with
them I'm just talking you know my
warrior culture against your warrior
culture in the way you live your life
you go meet some of these young soldiers
and Marines out there yeah you can come
and talk me into end Special Operations
guys you know what I mean obviously yeah
go come and get some yeah man dig it
come in fire for effect
sorry Brad it's I just learned the word
I'm translated in warrior culture
doesn't get through all of America you
know nonetheless we are down to support
ourselves I was going to make some
wisecrack about Hawaii but you know yeah
you might you might get done well not
going to do that yeah but no because
massive there's a there's a great book
that somebody sent me and it's about
japanese-americans that formed up you
know we sent Americans sent many
Japanese to internment camps in America
in World War two they also took a bunch
of them and turned them into a fighting
unit so the 442nd yes and they were they
might be the most highly decorated unit
of their of that size yeah because they
but a lot of them came from white yeah
yeah huge Japanese community in Hawaii
yeah yeah yeah and speaking of one cut
like a in Hall like the own warrior
culture why for sure yeah so you might
love they're just straight ups like a BJ
Penn right now yeah and my boy max
Holloway by the way by the way
champ yeah my mare max came and trained
with us
yeah after all for man what a border
beast yeah you know what he was training
hard yes he was training hard he wasn't
even close to UFC yet this was years ago
it wasn't close to UFC yet it's more
your culture at him yeah get some super
nice guy to when you when you consider
like even let's say the Spartans and you
consider all their battles and stuff
this is like hand-to-hand sword to neck
battle just like dang that's savage but
back in those days look at all kinds of
cultures so consider Hawaiian culture if
you look at the weapons like you can
look like in museums just go online
whatever look at the weapons that they
used in battle and then consider like
that's what you got to use it's like
savage meant like so we are there there
are a lot of legitimate warrior cultures
this is different there's no doubt and
what I'm saying to capsulate what I'm
saying this America has won yeah it's
yeah I'm totally tell with any adults
let me sleep on that so support support
wise I'm gonna shift gears here so we
you know idea talk about kettlebells
Volta I feel like I'm talking about keto
not just now I feel like I talked about
kettlebells a lot it's one of those
things you know how like you go from
thing to thing and you're like hey I'm
finna go to water cycle yeah yeah you go
from thing to thing well you know try to
acquired knowledge and we call skills
capabilities will say capabilities
that's important
participation is required kettlebells is
kind of like a thing that I recently got
into and I'm going to be honest this you
seem kind of good at them Brad you know
because consider kicks here's I'm going
to go into numbers whatever
so my metcon was is whit was um I'll do
135 greineder cleaning press Oh correct
whatever the presents are like just
pressing right jerk is kind of like yeah
you jerk your body kind of thing okay so
it's clean and jerk with 135 you know
the wheels oh five and then two burpees
walk for 30 to 35 seconds walk boom do
it again
so anywhere from I don't know to about 8
sets would be like a solid one usually
why you know 30 second walk by the way
it's like the recovery it's like it's
like you're breathing that's okay
so it helps wait why should I not do
that I know is that I've been over five
five five five now I wouldn't alright I
challenge you right now we're gonna do
it together and you just go five five
okay you can go longer well I don't want
to do that well my dad contest wouldn't
be to go longer well whoever whoever
stops the rhythm I'm saying that the
rest is but it's part because here's the
goal that's why well let me ask you this
I wanted to take you like 30 seconds to
do did you take 30 seconds to do the
five and five yeah no no more no no no
more than thirty so you do five clean up
press right boom five burpees yeah it's
one thirty seconds maybe 45 at the most
yeah yeah maybe 45 yeah I don't know
that's a good question it's 130 though
for sure okay well my guess it might be
all right so we'll put that on the timer
though you should I do say in like a
minute thirty I dress for 32 34 you
should be like okay I'm doing it all
because you're saying it like the tabata
like yeah well you should you you should
do a minute thirty seconds and every no
and every minute and 30 seconds you do
the five and five okay so that way you
get because by this by the sixth set
you'll be like tired when you're
starting it right but you don't arrest
more yeah push yourself this is kind of
my thought my thought process on it is
I'm gonna do a certain kind of work
capacity you know like a you know five
reps of this and fire up to this and
then I'm gonna have a have a kind of an
active recovery period walking yeah and
here's the thing and it's kind of the
goal this is good I actually I actually
am going back on what I said I think
this is actually not a bad idea because
but you need to put it's like when I do
sometimes do stuff on the minute yeah
what makes me nervous about what you're
saying is like I like less for about 30
to 35 seconds no I don't know what that
means okay because because that could be
40 seconds yeah that could also be it's
not you got a clock on yeah 100%
so the here's the weird thing about
having a clock but ever since I started
lifting rest between sets has been
critical part of by lifting reaching it
from the beginning rest between two
because there's just what I learned in
stuff like that
so I don't think the clock and actual
clock is not been a part of a work up
ever it's part of the wait wait wait
there's wait just like you're lifting
those weights that's what the weights
are for you're gonna rest in between
sets that's what the cost is for you
can't just go willy-nilly of your hair
I'll just order whatever looks good and
that's just myself if I'm not on the
clock of a one-hour workout for me it
would take like two hours yeah there's
I'll just I'll just be thinking about
something or I'll just take more rest
and I should have taken or whatever yeah
and consider this if you're doing let's
say you're doing five sets of squats
mm-hmm
if I said I don't know eight we'll say
no my you're pushing on your second set
you can do more weight than or less
weight then on your first set if you
rest for less time all right so if you
rest for five minutes you can do way
more yeah so that's putting your body
through something different than if you
would have just rested less so it just
depends on what you're trying to put
your body through well you can recover
from all kind of results those are just
our hardest workouts is and this isn't
this is an this one equals freedom
filled nail I used to do the 20 reps
squat workout sure which is you take a
weight that you can do ten times you do
20 times
kiss okay far and and it's all it's
devastatingly hard and I would rest for
20 minutes and then I would do it again
and then I would rest for 20 minutes
managing to get you froze because of
that that is okay so low tech man and I
believe you I'm not saying it's easy I'm
not saying that but that being said
technically that's impossible
technically yes you're right it is
impossible to do something and only need
10 times to 25 yeah if you can do the
weight that you rember and for 20 times
that's the way you can do for 25
straight at tennis so I get I get it
yeah yeah but I'm not gonna I'm not
going to you're right yeah but you also
understand what I'm not I know exactly
return like you're like a normal like
you're not maxing out at 10 reps on it
with this weight it that
but this is my normal maybe if I'm gonna
do a setting and we'll be surprised that
the way you can get like let's say you
know you you picked the right weight
that you can like I could use ten times
yeah legitimately and you're like you
know what I'm going to do it 20 times I
know less freedom
sorry I did it you're right and but I
think that's like a personalities kind
of situation like when you say I'm gonna
do a weight twenty times what I can you
know let's say for like about it are
normally do ten it's not normal also
you're like you're basically you're
resting as much as a human being can
rest with a bunch of weight on their
back in between reps we get to rep 12
you're taking like time but it's it's
it's a really it's a losing proposition
because while you're waiting they're
resting you're actually suffering back
start to get old me yeah yeah yeah get
over his squats are brutal because
you're not resting in an overhead squat
usually and it's like awkward and yeah
that that's hard the overhead squat
situation but and not to beat a dead
horse here so like consider if you said
hey someone who's pretty new more or
less to working out saying hey get it
wait you can do for ten and do it 20
they're going to mess up in one way to
probably they're going to be like okay I
can do this 10 times I know that and I'm
gonna try to do 20 if they can't even
get 20 because you said the way that
they could do for 10 they try for 20
they fail at 10 that's how much they can
do for 10 or they'll go the other way
they'll be like usually go get them and
they'll be like wait I got to do this 20
times goals yeah yeah I can do this I
can do the bar ten times so I'll do the
bar kind of thing so you have that
knowledge where you you're like hey I
know the weight that I do for ten and
it'll be hard but you know what I'm
gonna get nuts and if I really push
myself I can get twenty guess what I'm
using that weight so you kind of have
that because you've been trained if I
get anything yeah you're right and I
don't think I'll ever do that even
though I kind of considered it last time
you mentioned it but then when I got in
the workout room was like yeah then I
don't think I'll ever do that maybe I
will actually I'll tell you what I will
do is someone online maybe with you
someone was saying a hundred burpees in
ten minutes
that you say yeah yeah and Brent Brandon
just texted me yesterday
yeah great
where did you go to do it I was
considering I'm gonna do it in the first
time I do that hard I'm surprised at
branding Brandon's a good shape you ever
see he posts like pictures of himself
doing these crazy push-up workouts yeah
I can't believe he can't do it that's
why I'm so surprised
this is little guys weird yes good
creative push-up gels dozen your
creative push-up drills like well I
don't know he doings weird stuff and
puts his hands up here over there yeah
that's awkward yeah totally good yeah
cuz you ever straight like hey I got
good at push-ups when I was Lincoln X
I'm so pretty solid that push-ups but
you tried to a push-up with you know
yeah just and you're like oh this is way
off
kinda like good Specter seems like what
you used to you're doing or muscular
creature what we were saying we don't a
there something about gentle bone yeah
nice we kind of wrap up right now and
then you started talking about other
stuff
crazy squats and why not that's you know
what is my fault
next time I want anything yeah yeah see
that's like that's what I see what you
did there look you took blame you can
you told me what you're gonna do to fix
it extreme ownership in effect oh also
okay wait well what were we talking
about oh yeah I'm into kettlebells now
yeah and you want to say where you
should get your kettle off I'm not
saying that's where you should I'm
saying where I got them and if you want
you cattle bells anywhere where really
what about cool kettle bell okay whoa
that's a different story my friend
anyway I got mine from on it I'm not
even saying get the cool kettle bells
I'm saying go to on it calm flash Jack
oh look at the kettle bells you like
those kettle bells if you're gonna get
into kettle bells or if you're already
currently into kettle bells get someone
who knows if you like I like them I got
one the small one it's called howler a
little howler monkey mmm I think it's a
monkey
anyway howler monkey kettlebell it's
like once they 18 pounds let's 0.5 food
eight pounds prove you 16 pounds yeah no
no 16 kilos I think I'm sorry 16 girls
yeah yeah so yeah so eight kilos 16
pounds you ever take 17 18 months Oh
anyway I got one of those for my
daughter so
he comes visit he's 11 not into working
out we'll just say that yeah is now is
now yeah so I'm like you know he's one
of his kids he's like you know he's into
math and whatnot so I'm working out all
the time and I never really thought
until someone maybe kind of suggested it
to say hey come work out with me you
know so tell him come work out and he
kind of caught him at the end where it
was that con time and he and I was like
eight come worked out cuz I saw him you
know and he's like yeah is it cool
immediately dude by the way be surprised
I'm not surprised yeah man I'm surprised
you're working out there like man I want
to be like that yeah you know in their
hands I did remember you saw somebody I
was all yoked you're like Edie how do I
do that the whole reason I work out to
be honest would be like remember the
show American Gladiators I'm done yeah
but it was not from when I was a kid
yeah I didn't watch it the way you were
a parent yeah I was watching that I was
like bro I want to be American diet
because they were there it was like
because they were them the mix between
these big kind of almost like bullies
not bullies like not really people but
they were like you know when you play
video game you come against the boss so
you look at him you're like I can't beat
this guy I can't beat him oh yeah and
you're a normal character or whatever
and then they end up with that's what
American Gladiators was in real life I
was like dang this American Gladiators
their money because they're athletic too
cause like man I'd watch it I do a bunch
of push-ups up in like 68 isn't like
that yeah it's the whole reason anyway I
think a lot of kids have that in their
mind so she's boys for sure in one way
or another so I was like hey come work
out with me and use like like okay just
on this phone
yeah who's on the phone not anymore
full-out little Uncle Jake scenario
Uncle Jake 100% does it I was Uncle Jake
at that time legit nephew there really
actually UV to me I was visiting but
nonetheless he comes I teach him the
form and kids kind of have good form
what he did because they're flexible
yeah the flexible they haven't fallen
into like improper patterns
yeah maybe like like adults ever or
something maybe I don't know that's just
a guess but anyway so I'm like you know
just a basic kettlebell swing I say I'd
say this is what you're gonna do do it
I'll do it I'll show you how him little
little tips or whatever you know it was
a perfect form at first you just and you
could do it
not the kind of all the way up or
nothing just so basic I'm like alright
and my daughter happened to be there and
so she knows about burpees so it's like
okay what we're gonna do is room you're
going to kettlebell swings with five and
then you're going to do burpees and then
we're going to walk for 30 seconds
basically mimic but he's doing the
kettlebell swings rather than the clean
breath so then you need to do burpees
burpees just jump down do a push-up and
then jump up in there that's a burpee so
he does it I was like well I'm like you
know when you transition from standing
to pushup there's some wiggle room there
for air so I tell my daughter hey
demonstrate she does she's four so you
can do pretty good too right away so she
does it and I'm so of course he can do
it he's a little girl did so he doesn't
make the adjustment boom he's good to go
he's ready
so I mean fired out because mine's about
to be super hard like it normally is and
he's like he could tell he's getting
fired up too you know so I set the clock
and we go and it was kind of easy to be
honest with you because we had about for
each other yeah and boom that kid did
did the whole thing and he's not
sweating afterwards you know and he's
the kind where he doesn't do that kind
of stuff you know but you could tell he
was super fired up and you know what he
said next what he said afterwards he's
like hey next time you work out can you
let me know right up that's a good thing
uncle echos in now in the house man in
the house yeah so you had a book about
that yeah maybe maybe I will
it'll be the best book ever hit next
anyway
Kida let's go on it they have a lot of
good stuff you ever done battle ropes
before yes
you have a but not never have like
either in some random GM I was at right
I've seen people doing this i'ma do some
home yeah they're like big yeah big
ropes and they I guess that's a good
exercise for but I was considering that
it's awesome on there you know a lot of
good stuff on it calm slash Jocko check
out all the stuff really good stuff
stuff for everything basically
everything getting after it all so good
way to support is when you get your copy
of about face of course that's already
on it on our website dr. podcast.com
means that's the website if you didn't
know claw the clay pigeons of saint-lo
that's the current book we just went
over that one is on the website as well
section menu item on the top of the
website podcast comm click books from
episodes boom the list of book by
episode click through there yeah and
before you tweet me and tell me a good
book that I should do on the podcast
check and see if I've already done it
yes is like what like 60 books yeah and
a lot of really good books that everyone
knows but if you haven't listened to the
podcast and then you're telling me to
cover with the old breed by Eugene
sledge or whatever just a lot of times
people tell me to cover books that have
already been on there yeah so then I got
to go and figure out which podcast was
so I can tell you to go and listen to
podcasts you know 10 yeah which is what
the old breed by Eugene sledge though I
think yeah something like that but if
yeah hey hey you want to check that out
like I said it's all there by episode
yeah and if you want to book a reading
list for me that's my reading that's it
yeah there's no other books if the book
is good and I read it it's been on the
podcast and I'll do you one better
cuz I have a small reading list that I
added to that list oh it's only one book
but I'm just saying it might be nine
games yes Pawel my phone um you know
that's like easy read it's kind of like
the Field Manual small little version
different subject but nonetheless it's
not like a field rango did I reread it
but uh no no no probably not anyway back
since it is far supporting get your
books through there click through it
goes to Amazon you shop Amazon like we
all do anyway right so when you get
these books like I said listed by
episode click through there if you do
another shopping hey feel free you know
when you click through there that's a
small little action big reaction far
support so you know kind of like you
know when you throw sodium metal in
water you know oh I know yeah you know
but I haven't said it for a long time so
I'm gonna say it now just to remind
everybody when you throw sodium metal in
water it explodes big huge I learned
that in chemistry class my chemistry
teachers name is mr. Bigelow by the way
Kauai high school
darken the day anyway also a good way to
support subscribe to the podcast on
iTunes DJ Ango who play in other places
that they do podcast and leave a review
leave review here if you feel like yeah
that's really like reading the reviews
but yeah if you're feeling reading one
apparently it's like nope but boy I'm
aghast off I don't know yeah good good
and that's great for sure that's great I
know helpful Express yeah what does it
do spread the word and I think
ultimately that's the benefit so you
know when I see our Jaco podcast um you
know number whatever where it appears
like between 1 and 10 in the business
section that is good that's cool but
really the tangible benefit for the
message is is spreading the word people
if they get turned out - it improves
everybody's life really because if you
improve your life in in all these ways
it improves like your improvement is a
direct effect on my improvement because
I hang out with you so that's kind of it
so that's really the benefit so if you
want to help spread the word
ya can write a review and if you want to
give feedback about the podcast that's a
good place to do yeah I think that's and
let's face it when you leave a review
especially the ones that everyone leaves
because people are kind of fun that way
and people aren't people people like
take time in their reviews do not good
podcast yeah well actually sometimes did
you say that yeah yeah good
emphasis on capital G ood yeah that's
nice layers mmm
ladies in the review expecting they're
everywhere so I'm telling you but anyway
yeah a look if you're in the mood leave
a review
you know as long as you're honest that's
the main thing and you know get colorful
with it if you want those are actually
fun ones like I said yeah we review yeah
sure if you if you feel like it
subscribe subscribe to YouTube we have
YouTube if you didn't know everyone
knows I think yeah yeah cuz we see it
all the time but in the event of this
video why wouldn't I subscribe to it
then why wouldn't why wouldn't someone
subscribe to it if I were a person who
all wait if you're looking at the
podcast it makes sense yeah I don't know
how many
there would ever be to not welcome you
here this is what the reason I lived in
vodka I saw do I look I go to youtube
and I only watch people playing
first-person shooter video games you
know how that I don't know if you know
this but that's the thing like people
will watch other people yeah on YouTube
videos playing shooter games okay let's
say I'm only into that I'm probably not
going to subscribe or actually this
one's actually legitimate one that I can
kind of dig and relate to is if my
YouTube subscribing situation is only
two kids stuff only tickets up because
every once in a while I give my phone to
my kid okay and they watch like you know
they watch like Peppa Pig I don't know
something well and then you they click
because a lot of times the podcast is
just what the podcast is on YouTube but
like the other day you released a
deleted scene what he believes is a pre
recording we were just talking yeah
before and people seem to think it was
pretty funny yeah even I thought it was
glad but well yeah when you detached it
is really boiling other thing is if
someone wasn't listening if someone's
not on subscriber YouTube they would
never know that that existed yeah and
then you missed it initial pretty funny
yeah I thought it was funny too yeah
even though it's kind of kind of harsh
you know would you call me getaway
sticks or something like that mess stuff
anyway yeah see now you're you just went
into the reasons to subscribe
oh there's a hole good because you know
the excerpts that we make put out just
cut tiny segments three minutes nowadays
even though that you're likely to see
with 16 yeah you know that's different
but not as pretty funny yeah about the
excerpts you know they're just like
individual ideas that you talk about
boom shareable all good that's a good
reason to subscribe to YouTube one of
the many my opinion also chocolate is a
store it's called chocolate or chocolate
or Comcast a URL on there what do we
have shirts
rash guards rash guards out we started
four jiu-jitsu but here's the thing rash
guards are for surfing and bodyboarding
and jacking steel jack and feel yes
cycling these are all that's what really
like I say it's a spandex shirt there's
little things yeah I definitely term
rash guards only applies to surfing and
you're not worried about getting a rash
on your weight you're not worried about
getting a rat I guess yeah I guess did
you do the chapter eight yeah I guess so
yeah guard you against rational or
ringworm or whatever yeah it has be yeah
so nonetheless I mean the point there is
that it's for everything just because
you're jock was talking about jiu-jitsu
although I know it's not for everything
because I don't want to get you at a
club in a in or get after a rash guard
well that's you can speak for yourself
because if I saw someone at the club
with a get after it rash guard I would I
would say good evening to that person
that's your boy and I don't ever say
thank you don't be mad I don't know okay
Kevin
no no rash guards when you're out not
doing activities I'm not a supporter of
that yeah you know what to be actively
be completely honest I don't know that I
would support it right I mean just like
hey I'm going out I'm going to
supermarket put on my get after a basket
yeah I guess if you do that like you
never know what's going to happen yeah
you might want to be ready right that's
true yeah yeah you get some good
workouts in the grocery store yourself
in the 64 you know long line yeah so
you're in the rash guard your
compression you're ready it's absolutely
true and you know you want to look into
that go to jungle store come
so the shirts on there I think I try to
add like a new one every what like month
or you know I don't know what your goal
is
yeah I don't know if I we have i I've
been wearing Bronson's children t-shirt
me do yeah that's the worry because
that's that yeah don't yeah this shirt
that you made gonna do it going that you
made with my face on it or whatever
thing so I'd always get caught up on the
front like haha that's funny
the front and all the layers on the
front but on the back it says good
evening so when you wear that one that's
when people are going to talk to you the
most you know like you don't worry the
one with your face on it ever do you
know there's no reason for you to okay
yeah it would be weird if they I don't
have my face yeah you need to lure in my
favor
yeah exactly enough you know look at
that um but if you wear that one it's a
good evening on the back so I I never
really thought of if I haven't worn it I
don't even have one but that's the one
I'd wear this one looking good
people will say something they were like
good or good is backward you're sure
it's backwards I don't know or who's
that guy in your shirt whatever people
will say something get the good evening
one they'll talk to you even more but
they'll do it from behind they'll tell
you good evening every single time
interesting you haven't worn it yeah how
do you know there's no cuz I know and I
know the compulsion like I know the
feeling that's my hypothesis anyway and
from what I hear from the field anyway
go on there if you like something get
something that's a good way to support
there's some hats oh really
release coming out within one week how
about that cool okay all right there it
is I better have like nine of them lined
up at my doorstep I cuz I need some of
them have you got it right I promise
oh so yeah some patches on there as well
anyway check it out if you like
something get something also
psychological warfare you know what that
is it's an album with track Jaakko
tracks
jaco talking getting you through various
points of weakness in your and I've been
really trying to think of a word to say
other than journey
I haven't yet or in stick with journey
so when you're on your journey tours
you're trying to wake up wake up early
maybe I will do it you're trying to work
out or you're too casual you're trying
to work out everyday everyday now even
on rest days you're doing in mobility
water pressure like this yeah
man sometimes you want to turn those
those workout days interests days so
don't do that and if you need a little
spot with that you listen to
psychological warfare that's a track for
for any point of weakness like I said
get after it psychological warfare
Amazon music iTunes various other mp3
outlets Joe :
now first if you haven't heard yet we
are now in league with origin USA no
company that we are now a part of is in
months in the making
we've been going back and forth with my
boy Pete Roberts and who actually this
is you wonder about layers the reason
that we are linked up in the beginning
was because of Sarah Armstrong sure who
heard me talking about how cool origin
was yeah that they make everything in
the America and she sent Pete an email
and said hey I run this company and this
guy was talking about you you guys would
talk to each other
guess what we talked and now we're
getting after it and we joined forces so
we're playing in all kinds of things and
gear DS rash guards planning some
supplements believe it or not is the
rash crack that can stop not yet we were
doing a little we're doing a lot of
building right now yeah yeah
but we got all kinds of things coming
basically you know basically I want to
make everything that I use to get after
it
yeah I want to make a zoo so so
everything and I'm and when I say
everything is not a long list I don't
use that much stuff to get after it yeah
I use a pretty small list but I want to
make it and I want to make it them in
America so if you want to check it out
check out origin Mein Kampf because it's
in New England which one I'm from ding
no big deal Ayers layers indeed and also
if you want to get into it like now you
want to find out really what's going on
there's an origin immersion jujitsu camp
in Maine I realized I hadn't even
explained what this is you ever see Lucy
I'm from New England so I know what this
is I know what if camp is you you may or
may not know people and other parts of
course you may or may not
a camp in this form is in this situation
it's Big Lake and on the lake here is a
property and on the property they have a
bunch of little cabins a bunch of them
like multiple cabins and when you go to
a camp you stay in the cabins and then
they have a kind of a central area but
well we are renting out the entire camp
our how many cabinets like dozens and
dozens of cabins right all these things
on a lake and then there's a main kind
of gathering area well guess what we're
putting in the main it guess what we're
putting in the main gathering area let
on max it's so we're to go you know if
you want to come you come up you come to
Maine it's three hours from Boston it's
and half an hour from Augusta Maine
we're gonna be there echo and I are
going to be there Tuesday Wednesday and
Thursday there's two sessions that are
going on the first one is the 20 the
20th through the 23rd I think yeah the
23 23rd so echo not going to be the
Tuesday Wednesday fair so we're going to
be a part of both sessions and so come
to that and what we're going to do is
we're going to train to jitsu but you
can only train jiu-jitsu so many hours
day so what else we're going to or hang
out with a cruise please big time we're
going to do some kind of there's a big
lake there so you can't surf in the lake
but we'll figure something water
activity out right sure and we're making
lobster and I don't like lobster but I'm
gonna have steak and you can have
lobster and and yeah so we'll be hanging
out wait this is the lake is the lake
cold can you swim in the lake you can
swim in the lake really cold how cold it
is I don't know but I don't know the
temperature like but Maine summertime
it'll be it's not gonna be freezing okay
I don't think and if it is good to give
your muscles right recovery and also
during this so during the same two if
you come up or if you can't make that
you want to up through this anyways
we're having a grand opening of our new
origin factory in Farmington Maine so
big factory 20,000 square feet I think
it's bigger than 20,000 square feet
everyone's invited to that come hang out
you know thinking we do like we'll do
like a QA or something we'll hang out
we'll
bring books do this windows kick it so
come up to that that is the 23rd of
August in Maine common hangout like I
said what is the jujitsu part of it what
how does that work like the you know
there's two weeks you can go for the
whole thing
no it's not two weeks it's one week long
it's from the 20th to 27th but it's
brilliant watching sessions so so
winning mean sessions like what we all
just roll you have different teachers
they update your site yeah but being I
think we're doing I think it's three
sessions a day of jiu-jitsu yeah I mean
how many sessions can you roll hard apps
so some of them in their head you know
I'll drill some technique with you hey
maybe over some front lock stuff with me
or whatever you know what I mean yeah I
think there's gonna be some of that and
but then there's also a bunch of
different black belts going to be there
yeah Alex show moves yeah yeah so
immersion yeah immersion that's how you
learn not so I do not go Nolan's coming
back from the West Coast first uh he's
coming out he's he hit me up so yeah
come on up to that we have a good time
also when we're there we're gonna have
some chocolate white tea so if there's
anyone that wants to instantly deadlift
eight thousand pounds you can get the
chuckle white tea if you need to crush
an academic test get chocolatey if you
need some right now you get some on
Amazon books we'll get some books for
your kid or whatever kids you know we
got the way the warrior kid there's
lessons in there for everybody check it
out
if you want the first edition of
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
order it soon or go to your bookstore
and tell them you want to get it
preorder it whatever you got to do
Amazon Barnes & Noble's your local
bookstore get it now I'm going to tell
you don't get this book for your
wine-sipping book club not a book for
them they won't like it
you're part of that Club don't get it
for them you can still get it but don't
bring it to the book club
yeah they're there they're sipping wine
they're not in a game but if you want to
get stronger tougher smarter healthier
and more prepared all-around better
person get the book
Pinnacle's freedom field manual comes
out October 17th which means they're
printing it almost now hmm
so that means if you don't order it is
there'll be backed up you're not going
to have it everyone else is going to
have it you can have an edge on you
maybe you never recover like that battle
I was talking about earlier you know
someone else gets the edge but you just
says make it all so extreme ownership
own it refer to it highlighted implement
it spread the word get it for your team
your company or organization wrote that
with my brother lace babban so if you
don't have that and you have copies for
every single person that you've ever
known data form also echelon front
leadership consulting assessments
instruction me wave Babb and JP Danelle
Dave Burke get the team organized and
coordinated for action and for victory
that's my recommendation if you want to
get that process going email info and
echelon front calm finally the muster is
September 14th and 15th in San Diego all
the other masters at sold out more than
half the tickets for San Diego have
already sold out so this is going to
sell out don't get left out in the cold
you can register it extreme ownership
calm and if you need to talk to us
before you see us at the immersion camp
in Maine and before you go to the muster
in San Diego you can find us on the
interwebs the Twitter the Instagram that
Facebook ebo hot and although snapchat
you're on snapchat I'm on it I'm
learning from my children okay good
that's the way people communicate now
this is nap chat and I love a lot of
pages guess what Wall Street Journal's
on there The Economist is on there it's
not it's not this thing for your teenage
14 year old kid anymore well it is but
yeah well maybe I got out of the
basement is also the main group
No and you something to it I don't know
I'm talking rubbish but I have a snap 10
I don't use it and I have it like you
know I think you gotta like confirm your
account I was doing because my daughter
likes to make the faces yeah yeah crazy
faces my young started let's do that
yeah so she did it on my wife's phone
all the time and then she hit me up for
it like hey let me do she call it snap
chaps so she's like let me snapchat she
doesn't know what it the issue this is
just a safe inning I'm like alright so I
tried to do it and so I'm not gonna
confirm I was like nah so I didn't but
I'm yeah I guess I'm like one foot in
one foot out kind of thing well I'm not
read anything yet I'm going I almost
didn't I was like trying to figure it
out yeah yeah have a gay man but J told
me this is what J told me which was
smart yeah this is what J told me your
brother Jade I said you know what's just
I don't really understand it and he goes
that's why you need to do that Mel
really like wow I shit myself okay
you're right
you don't like oh I'm afraid of
something why am I afraid of it don't
understand it how do you overcome that
yeah cuz apparently it's a good method
again and then J and not to say Jade
said so so it's right I'm not saying
that but he's real smart with that kind
of stuff like he knows he see he knows
the trends we can like predict shit
stuff like how you know how like how
it'll work and who's gonna is in fact
what he does now is AI artificial
intelligence with applications and stuff
like that so he knows that stuff so it's
like when he kind of said he cannot but
be like yeah you're right you know even
if you don't know you're like well
consider the source kind of the in fact
he got me into cryptocurrency investment
there's my investment and I'm up 30%
that's all I'm going to say about it so
like I hate to giving him the credit for
that but you can't help it yeah well you
can find us on the interwebs
Decco is at Echo Charles and I am at
Jocko will Inc and finally thanks to
everyone that makes this podcast
possible first our military whose
strengths and true warrior culture
allows us the freedom to do what we want
to do and thanks to the
lise law enforcement firefighters
paramedics first responders who are ever
vigilant and always ready I was just
driving back from Yosemite and there big
forest fires up there and all kinds of
people had signs out saying thanks to
the firefighters so thanks for you guys
up there in the mountains fighting the
fires and to the rest of you that are
out there working building making and
squeezing every ounce of life that you
can crushing every minute of every day
out there leading in the face of
adversity and doing everything you can
to be everything you can to all you
thanks for being in the game with us and
thanks for getting after it so until
next time this is echo and Jocko out